Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Der chat wacht auf
Ja ich bin doch nicht lange auf also ich bin schon lange noch auf dass ich habe ein brötchen mit nutella gefunden das war es also mehr
Habe ich nicht gemacht
Weil ich es nicht gern im stream
Ausnahmen bestätigen die regeln wenn es gar nicht anders geht aber sonst muss ich euch nicht unbedingt unnötig ins ohr schmatzen
Einmal heißt es Ostern oder heute Sonntag? Exzellent
Das heißt für alle massive kläubigen ist das heute der wichtigste tag im jahr? Für mich nicht aber jeder wie er will
Das wirklich wach bin ich schon hätte nie kaffe ich trinke einen kaffee ich trinke einen kaffee
Wieso ich bin auch ganz normal war 23 oder so was im bett
Nö als hört ihr euch alle top fit an wenn ihr aufgestanden seid
Ja
Ja Beleuchtung ist echt so ein thema für sich meine deckenbeleuchtung sieht auch nicht schön aus das ist einfach eine fassung die andere die einfach an einem kabel runterhängt mit
Also in der mitte von der decke sieht nicht schön aus ich habe hier im arbeitszimmer nenne ich das mal ich habe hier nichts um die lampe hängen das hängt einfach eine lampe random an der decke
Ne würde mich selber interessieren
Und da meinst du welche die du in den direkt in switch also dass du einem sfp plus port den aj 45 kabel rein stecken kannst da gibt es paar gute aber welche die direkt irgendwo mitten im gebäude anschließen kannst auf der einen seite ein glasfaserkabel rein auf der anderen seite ein netzwerkabel rein keine ahnung habe ich mich auch nie mit beschäftigt hast du mal was mit sql gemacht ja gut die frage ist wer hat noch nicht mal irgendwann
nicht mal irgendwas mit sql gemacht klar habe ich das aber ich vermeide es
ehrlich gesagt soweit möglich was direkt mit sql zu machen also wenn
natürlich so dass es eine komische datenbankstruktur ist oder man irgendwie
die letzte performance braucht oder so dann kann man das sql machen
by the way sequel oder sql chat was sagt ihr was was ist die was ist die richtige
aussprache ich bin ja für sql oder es oder noch deutsche sql ich bin für sql
ja aber wie gesagt versuchst du meistens zu vermeiden in so gute
mechanischen tastatur umzudrehen zum spielen oder zum arbeiten zum arbeiten kann
ich dir nur das da empfehlen irgendeine davon die ist wirklich poggers aber die
mit aber die mit numpad ist huge aber zum spielen würde ich sagen ist es jetzt
vielleicht nicht so die allergeilste zumal es keinerlei macrosoftware bei den
tastaturen gibt zum spielen nicht ich hatte zum spielen hatte ich eine
korsarka 95 die würde ich auf gar keinen fall empfehlen
ja habe ich mir daheim gekauft damals ungefähr zum gleichen zeitpunkt wie ich
mit die ducky skyline gekauft habe kann ich gar nicht empfehlen die tasten fühlen
sich äußerst rutschig an haben doppelte tasten anschläge gehabt bei mir diese
diese leiste hier neben verwirrt auch unglaublich weil man ist normalerweise
gewöhnt der linke äußere rand der tastatur ist
control und hier sind es irgendwelche makro plöcke die handballenauflage war
nicht sonderlich bequem also die wird auf jeden fall nicht empfehlen
aktuell habe ich irgendeine logitech logitech g 513 so gibt so was so was habe
ich aktuell es hat auf jeden fall eine angenehme randballenauflage
die ist aber glaube ich nicht komplett mechanisch aber ist in ordnung
weiter weil viel zu teuer ja so was hier in dem dreh und besser warum ist das
warum ist das so teuer das habe ich im leben nicht dafür bezahlt
ich habe im leben moment warte mal ich muss mal kurz gucken was ich bezahlt
habe nicht so viel wollte mich verablen amazon
warte mal search amazon or das
e 513 search
ich habe was wie oder details ich habe 139 bezahlt mit handball auflage
what the fuck ernsthaft warum habe ich so viel bezahlt mann
warum ist das scheiß eigentlich so teuer mittlerweile
ich habe keine g 513 die g 512 eine g 512 was ist der unterschied zwischen der
g 512 und g 513 was da der unterschied e 512 ah ach so die hat die handball
auflage ach ja ach so ok dann ist die überschrift komisch ja schmidt
2 802 dankeschön 6 monos subscription also ich habe eine wire tastatur aber
eine wireless aber eine aber eine wireless maus
was ich auch echt cool für mittlerweile
also muss sagen wireless maus ist tatsächlich echt nice was ich mich die
ganze zeit schon frage ist warum gibt es das mx 300 mich als wireless bei
dynamics könnte ich huge money verdienen mit
wenn das nicht geil wenn es das einfach wireless gibt
stimmt die haben keine num block led das verstehe ich auch nicht da muss man
immer random checken ob num lock an oder aus ist aber so ein mx 300 wireless
wäre doch echt ultra nice meinetwegen können sie es auch so machen dass es
dass es in custom funk gedöns ist oder so egal ob das funktioniert entwickeln
das mx überhaupt noch weiter ja die machen immer mal in den refresh wurde
es dann aus und ein bisschen anders aussieht
ja jetzt sieht das so aus und aus meins hatte noch so ein komisches
zwischenzeit mal genau mein sieht so aus
meins sieht noch so aus wobei ja außer dass es ein bisschen gelb ist schon aber
meins ist ja auch alt ich mein guck mal ich habe das mx 300 weiß ich ob ich das
mal
hier guck mal das habe ich 2012 gekauft mit einem astro mix m den ich nicht mal
verwendet der aber ganz cool war für die konsole damals da war das noch da war
das noch frisch und grau jetzt ist es eher ein bisschen gelb licht
das mx 300 da kommt nichts dran das ist echt das beste es gibt sicherlich
andere die auch gutes preis leistungsverhältnis haben und nicht
schlecht sind aber ich habe noch nichts gesehen was ans mx das einzige wirklich
das einzige was mich am mx 300 ein bisschen stört aber das ist nichts
optisches ist und das liegt wahrscheinlich da dran weil es hat ja
auch gerade schon einer im chat gesagt dass es vom dt 770 abstand dass es
nen tick zu bass badewannen mäßig ist für manche für manche sachen aber das
man gewöhnt sich auch dran ja und im zweifelsfall kann man ein bisschen an
an seine mix m oder irgendwie rumstellen dass ein bisschen ausgleichen aber ein
bisschen badewannen mäßig ist es das ist das einzige was mich stört
und wenn ich einfach nur so vom rechner sitze
und ohne ohne schieben und ohne wo ich halt keinen kein mikro brauche
normalerweise würde ich da auch also vom vom klang rein vom klang her ich nehme
jetzt mal die hier das ist glaube ich die folgen die nachfolge davon
da würde ich eigentlich eher die hier aufziehen aber ich habe noch die alten
ich habe noch die alten die oben diesen die oben diese knubbel haben und ohne
scheiß ich komme mit den knubbeln nicht klar das das tut mir auf dem kopf wehen
nach zwei stunden vom sound her finde ich die insofern besser die klingen
deutlich neutraler als das mx 300 dafür haben sie halt kein mikro klar man kann
den mod mit dran machen oder so aber rein vom klang gefallen die mir eigentlich mit
am besten aber die knubbel sagen mega es gibt ja auch irgendwelche mods die die
knubbel ab flexen und dann irgendwie schaumstoff dran machen oder sowas
was hsc 271 ja die haben auch keine knubbel mehr die ganzen knubbel sacken
halt mal mega kostender kram jedoch oh ja das sieht extrem bequem aus
ja aber insgesamt muss ich sagen ist es echt immer noch das best derzeit ich
verwende es für alles auch auf der arbeit wenn wir irgendwie team teams
calls haben ich sitze da immer mit meinem mx 300 rum und es haben schon so viele
leute auf der arbeit gesagt haben wir machen so eine gute audio qualität wie
machst du das sagt ich habe einfach ein gescheites headset klar ich könnte auch
voll übertreiben und mein fettes mikrofon davor stellen und kopfhörer
aufziehen das klingt dann noch besser am besten noch mit irgendwelchen sound
settings dabei aber das ist mir zu anstrengend aber im vergleich zu dem
wo die meisten leute im homeoffice sitzen ist das der witz am schlimmsten finde
ich die dieses bild in laptop mikrofon verwenden das ist wirklich echt
abartig wir haben auch einen bei uns im team der hört sich an als hat er das
mikrofon echt keine ahnung als hat das irgendwie bobs stecken und und redet
quasi mit einem also das hört sich wirklich das hat ich versucht es mal
nachzustellen ich habe keine ahnung ob ihr überhaupt was hört jetzt und du
verstehst echt gar nichts ja ja der funktioniert aber irgendwie ist die
webseite nach ein paar stunden nicht mehr erreichbar
immerhin ist das mikrofon bei dem dann insofern ganz gut dass das eine gewisse
richtwirkung hat und man nicht dann irgendwie frau kinder haustiere mit
der grundhört welche maus maus habe ich aktuell ich habe total viel logitech
kam eine pro wireless mit dieser passende unterlage dazu die unter gibt
so eine maus unterlage die lädt die maus auch auf wenn sie drauf steht das ist
eigentlich ein bisschen wahrscheinlich induktion mäßig eigentlich eine coole
coole sache ja die maus hier wieder und hier als unterlage ich weiß gar nicht
wie diese unterlage heißt aus platt das da genau das da was die maus auch
auflädt finde ich cool ich musste jetzt also ich habe jetzt eine wireless maus
und musste die maus quasi seit ich habe immer aufladen ist echt angenehm und ich
muss sagen ehrlich gesagt ich merke dass die lei nicht zwischen wireless und und
kabel
je pro ist jetzt so groß ok ich finde die nice ich finde die nice was ich an der
markt ist die ist nicht ganz so schwer die ist relativ leicht dies nicht so
leicht wie so eine so maus die absinthe wirklich auf leicht gebaut ist aber die
ist immerhin noch deutlich leichter als negi was negi 503 war die fette genau das
ding ist ja mega schwer das wiegt er irgendwie karnung 250 gramm oder so
und du kannst auch kannst auch gewichte rein machen also das ding ist ist echt
krass zu schwer gewischt gut nur maus ja und die also die
pro die die wiegt wahrscheinlich 80 oder so würde ich mal schätzen ja genau 80
gramm ja das ist schon unterschied also 120 oder 80 das merkste extrem den
unterschied es gibt noch mäuse die sind noch ein
bisschen ein bisschen leichter gebaut aber ja ich ich finde es so ein ganz
nice 25.600 dpi ok das braucht kein mensch aber ja große zahlen verkaufen
sich halt gut das wissen wir was es gibt ultra leicht
super leid exe warum ist die weiß gibt sie auch in schwarz ich mag weiße
mäuse nicht ich habe immer schwarze mäuse einzige einzige maus die ich hatte
die man nicht schwarz war war so eine olle micro kennt die noch einer in
telly maus explorer kennt dieses teil noch einer das war glaube ich die
einzige maus die schmatt nicht in schwarz war ist das schon black facing
wenn man sagt man ist benutzt nur schwarze mäuse
schau dir die mal an an box leitest gaming maus
so wie soll man damit spielen wie soll man dann damit spielen was ist das für
ein ding
ok 23 gramme ist eine hausnummer aber wie soll man denn damit spielen
what the fuck was ist das sieht aus wie ein ding aus dem 3d trocker cute maus
ja der link funktioniert irgendwie nicht damit kannst du noch nicht spielen
das erinnert mich daran wie die halo pros früher früher gespielt haben auf
dem controller die haben auch alle entzündungen am
handgelenk bekomme xbox claw grip guckt euch das mal an also wenn du dein finger
kaputt machen willst dann spielst du so ja
das haben die gemacht dass sie in halo club gleichzeitig ein und springen
konnten und solche dinge das hatte schon sein sinn aber ich weiß ja nicht ich
weiß ja nicht also die ok mal ehrlich die maus die ist einfach nur leicht
die ist einfach nur leicht aber das war es auch der zauen könig m1 k ok was
kostet das heißt nicht wirklich zauen könig m1 k oder zauen könig punkto als
alle sieht auch noch hässlich aus es kommt ja auch noch dabei die sieht ja
auch noch nicht mal gut aus level up your mail your aim ich würde sagen die
könnten mal ihr html und css uplevel wenn ich mir die webseite so angucke
die karbon maus
ich weiß nicht ob man damit gut spielen kann ich habe irgendwie meine zweifel
es sieht ein bisschen aus wie aus dem 3d drucker
er ist auch aus dem 3d drucker nur oder staubt auch richtig heftig schnell ein
und es hat kein mausrad ja das kannst du kannst du vergegen
dedicated finger fingertip design ja mal davon abgesehen kennt ihr jemand der
wirklich ausschließlich fingertip kripp spielt also ich muss ehrlich sagen die
echt ernsthaft jetzt also das meiste das meiste was ich bisher gesehen habe ist
die spielen so ein zwischending also komplett komplett palm kripp spielt auch
keiner so komplett palm kripp spielt auch keiner so komplett ganz ehrlich ich
glaube so eine mischung so was hier in der richtung ist das normalste du hast
du hast quasi die finger ein bisschen angewinkelt und neben hast du den daumen
so dran und die maus ordentlich festzuhalten also ich glaube so was hier
in der richtung ist eher eher so was hier zwischen diesen zwei dürfte so das
normale sein echt gibt es wirklich leute die quasi
komplett so naja gut jeder wieder mag ja aber unbequem
kennst du rocket jump ninja nein habe ich schon nie gehört es muss in
mittlerweile macht ja auch jeder seine eigene maus ich brauche maus die
wubbler maus die hat dann die hat dann den knopf für für den jibaytet song
das ist das feature schlechthin und in voice assistant eingebaut den man mit
hey poggers starten kann das ist doch was die wubbler maus die
bekommt ein knopf wo man in jibaytet song starten kann und knopf wo man voice
assistant starten kann den man mit hey poggers anredet der kann dann zwar
nix aber der wacht mit hey poggers auf das machen wir ja wie gesagt das ist die
einzige maus die ich bisher glaube ich in meinem ganzen leben hatte die nicht
stimmt nicht die stimmt nicht stimmt nicht ich habe noch mal eine microsoft
wie ist diese diese office diese office ergonomik maus die meine ich nicht ich
meine die ganz alte alt die da meine ich microsoft classic in telly maus
genau die hatte ich auch noch in weiß aber ansonsten ich hatte nur schwarze
mäuse bisher weil ich weiß ich dass das ist auch weniger dreck drauf oder so ist
einfach besser und davor hatte ich die hier aber auch in schwarz war der hat
mir das mausrad beide überhaupt nicht gefallen
die mochte ich weil die ist auch relativ leicht gewesen aber das mausrad war
monac s die hatte ich nicht hat noch keine ffk 23 fk 2 ach fk 2 ist die
unergonomische nee ich habe absichtlich die die ergonomisch geformt ich mache
ego ergonomisch geformte maus ich weiß ich weiß meine g pro wireless ist auch
nicht ergonomisch geformt aber ich mag eigentlich ergonomisch geformte mäuse
aber das mausrad ist wirklich krabi totaler crap das best so ist ihr das
beste mausrad ich weiß es sehen viele leute anders aber ich finde das beste
maus rate mausrad war immer noch war der hier das mausrad war zwar laut es fack
wenn du da gescrollt hast war das wirklich also ungefähr in der
lautstärke nur durch den ganzen raum aber das coole war dass das so ein lager
hatte und du konntest das raus klipsen oder hat so ein endless scroll endless
scroll mal gucken ob es ein video von gibt es war echt nice hier
guck und jetzt gibt gas alle gibt gar jawoll das ist nice gewesen und die maus
habe ich immer noch auf der arbeit liegen und ich glaube ich nerv da manche
kollegen mit wenn ich ab und zu endless scroll mache mit der maus ich mache ich
mache zwischendurch wenn es mir langweilig ist immer immer mal den
widerstand raus und macht das immer noch bestes mausrad und das mausrad ist auch
trotzdem nice wenn es festgestellt ist die mx master macht das auto
automatisch wie macht man so was automatisch wo soll die maus wissen wann
ich endlich scrollen will und war nett weil ich ich mal tritt hier mein mausrad
normalerweise auch schon ganz schön
man kann eigentlich einfach ein endless nämlich das finde ich mit knopf
eigentlich was sinnvoller ja aber so viel zum thema mäuse ja ok gibt sie
moment wollte ich mal gucken wie viel wiegt die jetzt die wiegt nur 63 gram
ok das ist natürlich schon ziemlich leicht und dann gibt sie auch noch in
black gut den stick brauche ich nicht ich habe ja das gelb hat kostet
puh die maus und keyboard was ist das dann für den keyboard
jetzt was ist das ja das kann man sich kaufen das aber nur wenn es das
aufladbare gamepad ist da blickt blickt da keiner mehr durch was ist in der
unterschied gepro wireless kostet die kostet nur noch 100 112 aber ich mein
mal ganz im ernst 150 euro oder generell das andere ist auch schon zu teuer
ich mein 112 euro für eine maus das ist schon echt nicht ohne ich hatte ja
damals ohne microsoft office maus explorer oder sowas maus explorer
das war ich euch eben gezeigt wie ist das intelli maus explorer ja 1999 1990 die
fette hatte ich damals die da die da moment die gibt es noch zu kaufen
keck weight also heute würde ich die auch nicht mehr haben wollen die war aus für
heutigen maßstäben richtig crap die war richtig groß die war schwer die hat
einen scheiß sensor und du musst laufend a a batterien wechseln
1999 sti das war schon die andere ja das die richtig das die richtig old school
und ich war unten noch rot genau und war riesig fett ja mit so einem kack hat man
damals gespielt wireless schon nein es ist keine kabel maus ist eine wireless
maus wireless 1999 maus das war meine einzige wireless maus die ich bis bis
jetzt zur aktuellen hatte und die hat mich was zum geier ist mit der hier los
und die hat mich komplett versaut was das angeht und seitdem wollte ich nie
wieder wireless haben weil die so gesagt hat
ja die gab sicherlich auch mit kabel aber die gibt es auch bei alles und ich
hatte die weil das variante fand ich eigentlich am anfang furchtbar nice
weil ich es auch war nice wireless maus das ist die zukunft und dann habe ich
gemerkt das ding frisst batterien wie sau hat empfangsstörung und sagt
eigentlich nur noch damals hat die maus gerne mal so gemacht ungefähr so wie
wenn man eine maus heute auf auf klasse legt oder so so hat die maus dann einfach
gemacht du hast irgendwo hingezielt in einem spiel und die maus einfach so
gemacht also das war wirklich müll komplett
damit aber sowas von
also die neuen mauen die neun die neun wireless maus muss sagen finde ich
geil also ich war ja auch ich war lange zeit der meinung ich will kabel haben
und da habe ich die g pro wireless maus mal ausprobiert ich muss sagen ich habe
keinen unterschied mehr gemerkt ich habe hier neben dran am zweiten rechner ich
habe ja noch die g 403 da liegen die ist auch cool die ist aber so die wiegen
ungefähr gleich viel vielleicht ist die g 403 noch ein ticken leichter und ich
muss sagen ich merke da echt kein unterschied zwischen den zwischen den
mausen was input angeht und sonst was also du merkst du merkst keine
verzögern und es gab ja auch mittlerweile genug tests die gesagt haben
hey mit mit der aktuellen wireless technologie hast du im endeffekt keine
großartige verzögerung ich habe versprochen eine umfrage zu machen
stimmt heute ist ja ostern mott mott check wenn ein mott da ist kann man das machen
um frage ob ich ob wir weiter den weihnachts keck weh behalten oder den
normalen keck weh rein machen ich persönlich bin ja für den weihnachts
keck weh und an weihnachten mache ich dann wieder den normalen keck weh rein
ich habe eine gute frage ich glaube ich glaube du musst slash slash poll und
dann gibt es und dann kommt in den menü dann gibt es ein menü wo du auswählen
kannst was man fragen will da geht es um gui auf nene captain stripes machen
langsam ich glaube da ich glaube captain peng macht das ich glaube man muss
slash poll machen oder macht ihr macht ihr macht ihr macht ihr einfach mal
passt schon ja dann haben wir umfrage aber ich persönlich bin ja für den
weihnachts keck weh zu behalten also okay was gucken wir uns jetzt als
erstes an bett company to is still create after ne ne ne ne ten years later
okay check check frags hat meistens zumindest halbwegs gutes gameplay
was mich angucken kann komm wir gucken sie ist eine runde bett company 2 an easy
okay das muss man nicht unbedingt so viel autobahn man muss ja eins sagen im
vergleich zum aktuellen battlefield fühlt sich bett company 2 schon enorm
schwerfällig an
das muss man nicht hören ich laber da wahrscheinlich drüber ja ja du kannst
du kannst genau du kannst die typen ja du kannst die die spieler kannst du
daten und ja das ging damals erfreut sich auch okay ich kann lauter machen ist okay
ja kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen ich weiß doch wo wir das gewusst ist wo ich
die beta ich habe mit dem famian zusammen die beta gespielt auf der xbox 360
seht ihr mal wie alt das ist
in der beta hat man auch glaubt ein tick mehr ausgehalten da war das alles ein
bisschen anders getweekt
da gab es da gab es nur port walters in der in der beta und es war eigentlich die
beta war eigentlich beschränkt bis auf level 2 und es haben aber leute in
der beta geschafft tatsächlich bis auf level 3 hochzukommen weil die 24 sieben
gespielt haben okay behalten wir den weihnachts
keck weh oder den normalen keck weh
ok die aktie ok die umfrage sieht so aus als wollen die leute den normalen
keck weh zurück
ja war das zu play cops eins zeiten ja so so ungefähr ja
soll ich ich bin ein keks zur keckmaster zu zählen
Naja gut, ähm, dann guck ich mal, dass ich nachher wieder den normalen Keque reinmache.
Ich glaub das ist relativ eindeutig wie das ausgeht, aber ich mach nachher wieder den
normalen Keque rein.
Ist, ist glaube ich relativ eindeutig, ich glaub nicht das Keque-Mass jetzt noch irgendwie
großartig aufholen wird.
Ja wunderbar, gut, also Keque kommt wieder rein, der original Keque, ich Keque-Mass,
über welches Addon hab ich denn die Emotes überhaupt drinnen, zeig mal kurz her, Keque-Waite,
ja, über FFZ, FFZ ist es drinnen, FFZ, ich mach das jetzt gleich, sonst vergess ichs
wieder, FFZ, Emote-Library, Keque-W, buy Emotes, remove und add, so Leute, wir haben hier den
normalen Keque-W, aber das dauert, aber das dauert ein bisschen.
Ja, das, das sieht jetzt so aus als hätt's verloren, aber er hat's gewonnen.
Do never refresh, ja wenn du nicht refresh, dann bleibt der alte.
Was, was ist das für ne Frage?
Keque-W, chat, chat, Keque-Waite, ich muss das machen auf YouTube, natürlich kann man
die Katz ab und zu mal sehen, ich muss das machen auf YouTube, was die Leute auch sehen
wollen, ja in der Masse, auch wenn Katzenvideos ab und zu mal nice sind, aber, ich kann einfach
15 Sekunden von meiner Katze aufnehmen, wie sie am Waschbalken steht und macht, broadcast
yourself, das ist schon lange nicht mehr angesagt auf YouTube, weiß gar nicht, ob die das Motto
noch haben.
Man deabonniert heut übrigens auch nicht, man disabot heute, ich guck mal, dass ich
die Katzen bisschen mehr eingebaut krieg, aber ich kann keine eigenen Katzenvideos machen,
ich muss heut übrigens noch ein Video aufnehmen fällt mir ein, ich hab gestern,
mir ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht über Themen und ich hab keins wo ich gesagt hab, ey ich
muss jetzt unbedingt das jetzt sofort aufnehmen, ich hab ja auch ne riesen Themenliste, es
gibt genug, aber es war jetzt kein Thema dabei wo ich gesagt hab, oh ja, da muss ich ja instant
was zu sagen, weil ich da so scharf drauf bin, weiß nicht, muss ich mir irgendwas raussuchen
wo ich noch Bock drauf hab, warum hat die Katze nicht ihren eigenen Kanal, falls wahrscheinlich
keinen interessiert, warum muss man sich eigentlich diese Zwangs Corona News hier geben jeden
Tag auf YouTube, ich kanns nicht mehr hören und nicht mehr sehen, okay wo sind wir stehengeblieben,
hier Bad Company, exellent, die kann man ausstellen aber nur wenn man eingeloggt ist oder, so kann
ich die nicht ausstellen, kann ich die ausstellen, korruption, nein sowas gibt es hier nicht,
kann nicht sein, das kann überhaupt nicht sein, haben nicht letztens alle in der Regierung
eine Ehrenerklärung abgegeben, dass sie nicht irgendwie geheime Dinge machen und natürlich
glaube ich diese Ehrenerklärung, was denn sonst, also wenn man diese Ehrenerklärung
schon nicht mehr glauben kann, dann weiß ich auch nicht, ach nur die CSU, okay, na meinetwegen,
ja aber die sind doch so Ehrenmänner und Frauen, das kann man doch glauben, selbstverständlich,
xorix, danke schön für die 5 Monate, huge subscription, okay Bad Company 2 Video, ja tatsächlich,
das Spiel hat auf, das hat auf dem PC eine recht stabile Fanbase, die das immer noch
spielt und die werden das wahrscheinlich auch die nächsten 50 Jahre noch spielen, was
auch das schöne daran ist, weil das Spiel braucht ja keine offiziellen Server, die man
irgendwie mieten kann, also ja doch, du musst schon Server mieten, aber das kann prinzipiell
jeder machen oder auch selbst installieren, das ging noch, ich glaube das war das letzte
Battlefield, wo du selbst Server hosten konntest, so richtig, echt, komplett mit eigenem Server,
den man installieren konnte oder erzähl ich Mist, gab es danach noch eins, ich glaube
nicht, ich glaube das war das letzte Battlefield, wo das ging, wollte nicht jemals Battle Royale
dafür entwickeln, für Battlefield 3 wollten sie einen Battle Royale entwickeln und es
hatte echt noch ganz gute Spielerbase, erstmal Schneiber Action, die Motion Sensoren, die
Motion Sensoren waren halt, what the fuck, warum hat das nicht gehitted und warum sind
die Gegner immer noch so brain half k wie früher, übrigens wisst ihr was ist richtig
geil, was ich richtig geil fand an Bad Company 2 waren die Pistols, du konntest in dem Game
mit Pistolen übelst bashen ey, ja das ist diese komische kleine Drohne, wo es immer
welche gab, die am Anfang der Runde da dran gegangen sind und die restliche Runde mit
der Drohne rumgeflogen sind, ja M1911 heißt es wahrscheinlich, ja die M1911 war geil,
den glaube ich 3 hitted, Pistols hatten keinen Bullet Drop, das stimmt, wobei ich mir ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht sicher bin, ob SMGs und sowas Bullet Drop hatten, also Sniper hatten glaube
ich Bullet Drop, ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern, also Sniper hatten
auf jeden Fall Travel Time, wie es mit den normalen Waffen aussieht weiß ich jetzt ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht, ja alles nur die Pistols, ich kann mich daran erinnern, achja und was
das Spiel auch hatte, Server Side Hit Detection, du bist selten um Ecken gestorben, dafür hast
du zum Beispiel auf Gegner drauf geschossen und es kam dich an, da oben steht er im Fenster
hä guck, das war auch so ein Ding, ich hätte wetten können der Dude war drauf ne, guck
mal, naja ok, aber so genau waren die Hitboxen in dem Game ja eigentlich gar nicht, der war
drauf Leute, der war drauf, der hat voll gehitted, guck mal es gibt sogar eine Treffer Animation,
ne es gibt nen Sandspritzer, aber der war voll drauf alter, das ist halt Server Side
Hit Detection, auf dem Server war der halt nicht da, ja ja ja es gibt Panzer, also auf
Rush gibt es auf jeden Fall Panzer, in Conquest bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher,
ich hab dazu viel Conquest gespielt, also das Spiel hatte zwei geile Sniper für mich,
die SV98 und die 50er Caliber, diese fette, die Barrett aus M2, MW2, das fette Sniper,
es hatte eine längere One Hit Range, der Rest war auch cool, aber das waren so für
mich die Nicesten, zack in the Corp, jawoll, das ist M95 was der hat ja, zack, ja damit
das war das Medic Hütchen, das Medic Hütchen war das, die sitzen hier einfach nur rum und
bewegen sich nicht, in your face, ja Travel Time, oh nice, nice, nice, oh nice, übrigens
das ist das Ding an Sniper Rifles gewesen, was die übelst OP gemacht hat in Bad Company
2, das war das einzige Spiel, wo ich wirklich viel Sniper gespielt hab, weil die Dinger
eine übelste One Hit Range hatten und du konntest damit quasi, gerade auf der Konsole hattest
du auch noch Auto Aim beim reinzoomen, du konntest quasi in die Nähe des Gegners gucken, reinzoomen
und abdrücken und es wurde One Hitted, ich glaube damals hat man noch nicht gespiegelt
als Sniper, nee, zack, jetzt Pistol, in your face Pistol, bamm, bamm, bamm, jawoll,
die Pistols haben sich auch alle, die Pistols haben sich auch alle nice unterschieden, ja,
du hast eine M1911 gehabt, die hat halt gemacht Bup, Bup, Bup und hat die Leute 3 Hitted,
du hattest eine MP433 oder wie das Ding heißt, die konntest du übel spam, bamm, bamm, bamm,
also da konntest du wirklich Pepega Aim mit machen, du hattest eine M9, das war so dazwischen,
das ist übrigens eine Burst Pistol, die er hier hat oder, ah, der hat die, weil, ja,
der wird gestälzt, zack, ja und die Motion Sensoren waren halt das geile an der Klasse,
deswegen konntest du die auch offensiv spielen, die Motion Sensoren haben dir gar nicht so
viel gebracht, wenn du so diese Standard Sniper Action gemacht hast, wie sie das heute machen,
quasi sie sitzen im Spawn und gucken irgendwelche Long Range Dinger zu snipen, ich mein du konntest
die Dinger über die halbe Map werfen, aber so richtig cool war es eigentlich nur wenn
du nah dran warst, und was sie auch hatten, die LMGs hatten in dem Game übertriebenen
Muscle Flash, du hast kaum Gegner gesehen, wenn du geschossen hast, und du musstest Teppen,
also wenn in dem Spiel Dauerfeuer gemacht hast, warst verloren, du musstest eigentlich fast
jede Waffe, so Feuer, fast jede Waffe musstest du, oder insa war eine Saw, aber du musstest
auf jeden fall muss auf jeden fall tippen aber die dinge haben sich auch
sauschnell gesettet
bämen
das spiel sieht immer noch verhältnismäßig gut aus ja und ich glaube
euch mal dass das heißt das ist durchaus ok für ein spiel aus 2010
das stimmt, man muss echt sagen Battlefield 3 sieht nicht schlecht aus
wobei das auch nicht übel aussieht muss man da muss man schon mal sagen die
zerstörung war halt cool mit häuser die eingefallen sind und so aber man muss
sagen die zerstörung in bed company 2 die war nicht komplett hirnlos du
konntest basis strukturen auf der map die wirklich wichtig war nicht zerstören
du konntest beispielsweise in port wall das konntest du nicht die gerüste
zerstören und so was dafür die häuser es war aber trotzdem manchmal ein
bisschen zu viel gerade gerade weil pareiso oder so was in dem dorf da war ja
nach fünf minuten war nichts mehr übrig und du konntest nur noch übers freie
feld rennen
du konntest am kommst du konntest am kommst hier mit dem panzer zerstören
aus dem spawn deswegen konntest du arica harbor 1 base auch eigentlich nicht
halten wenn es die gegner gescheit gemacht haben
in ford well also halbwegs gescheit gemacht haben sich looking next gen game
coming out the next year with farshing and destruction and i just think that's
quite a funny position to be i'm gonna switch to assault
gip-gip medic ich ich will ich will medic muscle flesh sprain sehen die
gegner sind auch ganz schön low-brain so da
manche grenade launcher die skone hier ist okay die war kacke die hat mir nicht gefallen best assault rifle m16 burst glaub in dem
game wenn ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was best assault rifle gewesen ist
was auf jeden fall was auf jeden fall es war es war es waren wirklich so viele
waffen cool ja die um p.m.g. war halt auch relativ op und was halt richtig
ätzend war war shotgun slug ammo in dem spiel ist one of the quintessential guns
dieses scope ernsthaft dieses scope war richtig nice das einzige game wo ich
finde wo sich diese scopes teilweise gelohnt haben das war richtig nice auf
einer m60 m60 lmg mit diesem scope du kannst die gegner auch drei hitten über
übelste range
oh yeah feels good man habe ich das überhaupt noch installiert
bett bett hier habe ich nicht mehr installiert
das wird sogar in bc2 triffst du das sogar besser ohne scope weil da kannst
du einfach machen tap tap tap tap und natürlich ist tot wenn du das damit
probiert kriegste durch triffste durch wie viele leute spielen gerade wenn es
an liegst gar niemand wir gucken mal kurz wir gucken mal kurz wenn wir dabei
sind niemand niemand wahrscheinlich die haben
glaube ich immer noch den memory leak immer noch nicht gefixt und machen
irgendwie auch gerade nix richtig dett dett game
wo doch so viel
ja dafür kann man jetzt mit bots spielen ja super toll da kann ich auch
vanillaspiel gegen echte gegner
ich überlege gerade ernsthaft ob ich bc2 wieder installieren soll und man
paro einfach ich könnte ja einfach mal zwei drei runden spielen und dann
video zusammenschneiden draus wie geht denn das video bei dem oh das video
geht ziemlich gut ich mache einfach so ein rip-off video
die zwei zehn jahre später aber aber ich laber natürlich was eigenes zu
Also
Bäm Bäm Bäm
Richtig pfeifert ja
Wow habe ich das vielleicht auf dem zweiten rechner installiert
Das kommt ja hier habe ich noch installiert auch vom zweit rechner ok ok ok
Oh monke ist
Alter richtig ab
Es ist gut
Die klasse ist ein bisschen anders als wie sie es in bf 3 4 5 und 1
Auf wegsprengen
Aber ich werde glaube ich tatsächlich auch conquest spielen weil conquest kann man zwei drei runden spielen und hat auf jeden fall
genug so eins zwei minuten clips wo man
Video draus machen kann
Und ich kann mich immer noch an einen sound erinnern der mich auch übelst genervt hat weil in dem spiel haben auch viel zu viele
Leute sniper gespielt und immer wenn du angeschossen wurdest oder das an dir vorbei
Geflogen ist hat der typ gesagt it's a sniper
Das heißt es hat sie bis heute gemerkt
Motion motion sensor beste hier
Ich sehe jemanden sagen wir sind die sind die alle irgendwie ultra der oder was
Okay, ich hoffe ich habe auch so gegner dann
Dankeschön unic vier monate mehr selbst ab hier
Und
Okay ump ump beste engi waffe chat was sagt ihr falls überhaupt jemand gespielt hat
Ingenieur ump
Ich mein das kann ich auch der typ spielt eine runde switch die klassen durch macht da draußen video easy
Pp 2000
Ah
Leute um all the way um hier
Maybe getting a bit too pushy there
This is a medic
um beste
Ach ja übrigens übrigens
der defi
war so
Also absolut op du konntest durch wende wiederbeleben wenn du gesehen hast hier ist einer gestorben
Dann hast du einfach hier gegen die wand defied und dann ist ist der typ wieder aufgestanden
No revive animations here you get these nice lmg's with the medic class, which seems a bit weird
Absolute beamer's cool reload animation
Man hat glaube ich ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher hat man man hat hells gerecht, aber ultra langsam und man hat ja keine health anzeige
Ich weet es auf any moment ich weiß es wie die
Following
Und dann sieht ihr, ein Motorstrike kommt rein.
Und natürlich hat das mit der Destruktion in dem Spiel sehr gut gespielt.
Aber du konntest es auf M-Coms dropen, wenn das Spiel entstanden wäre.
Du kannst immer noch auf M-Coms mit dem Mörser-Schlag bashen. Vor allem du kannst die Leute vom Diffusen abhalten.
Deswegen, man muss ja immer den Diffuse-Dance machen. Man ist immer im Kreis um das M-Com gelaufen zum Diffusen, dass man nicht gehindert wird.
Ich glaube, das mache ich. Ich installiere mir Bits hier zwei später und spiele zwei, drei Runden Conquest und schnibbeln daraus was zusammen.
Ja, weil er nicht getroffen hat.
Und das allerwichtigste, Reload-Cancel. Das hat er jetzt nicht gemacht, aber Reload-Cancel war auch huge in dem Game.
Guck, wenn du geschossen hast und du wolltest nachladen. So, Moment.
Jetzt hast du die Waffen geswitcht und hast schneller Reloaded.
Und jetzt switchen und du hast nicht viel gespart, wenn es hoch kommt, eine halbe Sekunde. Eher weniger.
Easy, easy win.
Ich würde es nicht wundern, wenn ich heute 50 Abwandlungen von Covid und Corona wieder sehe als Gamertag.
10 Jahre später. Danke fürs Zuschauen. Ich hoffe, dass euch das gefallen hat.
Lasst mich wissen, was ihr Lieblingspart von Bad Company 2 in den Kommentaren unten unten war.
Ich weiß nicht, was dieser Wookiee hier tut.
Will er einen Dance-Off oder was auch immer?
Er sieht die Wookiee, ich kann nicht entscheiden.
Auf jeden Fall, danke fürs Zuschauen. Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, lasst ein Like.
Wenn ihr es nicht genutzt habt, abonniert euch noch mehr und ich sehe euch im nächsten Video.
Was willst du von mir, Wookiee? Bitte!
Ja, guck mal. Also ungefähr, sagen wir mal, eineinhalb Jahre war Bad Company 2 aktuell.
Das war's. Es kam mir viel länger vor.
Na ja, gut.
Es kam mir viel länger vor, wie aktuell das ist.
Du hast ein Cuts-FPS-Emote gemacht.
Oh, das ist nice. Leute, das füge ich hinzu, oder?
Cuts-FPS-Emote. Das hast du sogar noch richtig gut ausgeschnitten.
Das brauchen wir. Moment, Moment.
Es ist ge-edit.
Ist ge-edit.
Testen wir mal.
Moment, wie muss man es eigentlich schreiben?
Was?
Ne.
Ich refresche mal.
Wie alt warst du, als BC2 rausgekommen ist?
26?
26, vermute ich mal.
Okay, der hat's noch nicht erkannt.
Das dauert noch zwei, drei Minuten bis es kommt.
Ich bin 1984 geboren.
Richtig Boomer. Ich glaube, ich war 26.
Jetzt bin ich 36.
Und wenn es zehn Jahre her ist, kann das durchaus sein.
Der Chat kann es kaum erwarten.
Ja, ich refresche schon wieder.
Richtig Boomer.
Ist es noch nicht da? Aber ich hab's hinzugefügt, Leute.
Also, ich hab's ge-edit.
So, seht ihr hier auch als Beweis.
Ich hab's ge-edit.
Ja, da müssen wir kurz warten. Können wir gleich ausprobieren.
Kommen jetzt die Battlefield Leagues.
Stimmt.
Level Cap hat ein Video zugemacht.
Allerdings, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
die Level Cap Videos sind echt krasser Chebat in letzter Zeit, ne?
Also, der erzählt jetzt wahrscheinlich 20 Sekunden das, was wir eh schon wissen.
Und...
Dann macht er was anderes. Also, die sind schon hart Chebat.
Welches CMS würdest du für kleine Projekte verwenden? Kenne ich mich nicht mit aus.
Aber ich würde wahrscheinlich, egal für was, kein WordPress verwenden.
Einfach nur, weil WordPress so einen schlechten Ruf hat.
Vielleicht ist es mittlerweile gar nicht so schlecht.
Okay, erzähl, Alter.
Reached? Wo-
Wo-
Reached?
Peak Insanity? Also, was ich an Battlefield-
Lul, man kann es auch übertreiben.
Also, was ich mitbekommen habe an Battlefield 6 Leagues war,
dass es wahrscheinlich in der jetzigen Zeit minimal in der Zukunft spielt
und dass es einen Free-To-Play Battle Royale geben wird.
Alles, was ich sogar witzigerweise im letzten Video zu Battlefield gesagt hab
und was total obvious irgendwie ist.
Was klar war, wenn man sich Warzone anguckt.
Peak Insanity, ja, ist ja gut, Alter.
Gibt es ein Update, was nicht Disastrous ist in Warzone?
Jedes Update ist scheiß da doch voll rein.
Ja, das darf man auch von auszugehen, dass es irgendwie aktueller Zeit spielt.
Okay, ein Konflikt zwischen US und Cokomodates ist ja nur wirklich Battlefield-Standard schon.
Denen fällt auch nichts anderes mehr ein.
Ich hab echt den Eindruck, wenn die irgendwelche Story-Writer holen,
dann ist es Konflikt zwischen Russland und den USA,
mittlerweile eventuell noch China dabei.
Die Chinesen darf man ja mittlerweile auch nicht vergessen.
Die China-Chinesen, was ist Cuts FPS jetzt da? F5, okay, okay.
Testet mal, ist die Cuts da?
Nein.
Immer noch nicht.
Gebaided.
Bei dir ist es schon da?
Okay, noch mal reden.
Gebaided.
Nee, bei mir ist es doch nicht da.
Kein Gebaid, ich werde massiv gebaided.
Nee, bei mir ist es noch nicht da.
Nein, nein, nein.
Haha, null
Ich habe alles erfünft
Echt bei dir ist er da
Keck wait
Photoshopped fake photoshopped sehe ich sofort rein photoshopped leute
Es müsste aber eigentlich jetzt mal da sein
Ne es lädt nicht okay, wisst ihr was drauf geschissen wir probieren es nachher noch mal
Die legit wills aber echt wissen
Will offer a free to play battle royale mode and will simply be called battlefield
Oh nein, please, lend es nicht battlefield das macht ja alles noch verwirrender
Dann haben wir dann hatten wir battlefield
1942 dann hatten wir zehn jahre später battlefield
1943 dann hatten wir acht jahre davor irgendwie battlefield 2 dann haben wir battlefield 3 battlefield 4
Dann haben wir battlefield 1 dann hätten wir battlefield 5 und jetzt haben wir nur battlefield
Ok ok eins muss man ihnen zugute halten vielleicht gestehen sie sich dadurch auch einfach ein
Die benahmung ist eh komplett abfuck und wir können es jetzt eigentlich nennen wie wir wollen
Over on 4chan an anonymous user posted a leaked ea das wissen wir ja dass das schon mal prinzipiell äußerst vertrauenswürdig ist wenn es auf 4chan gepostet wird
An anonymous user posted a leaked ea play live schedule
Wobei man halt sagen muss da gibt es auch die ein oder anderen sachen die stimmen
Make some dubious claims like apex season 9 getting a trailer a month after the current season ends it does list a
Release date for battlefield 6 according to the leak ea play live will happen on june 14th and battlefield 6 will launch on november 19th a
Reveal for battlefield 6 is likely happening in may with a cinematic trailer ea play live will offer a gameplay trailer and
Developer interview with dice one last interesting thing about this ea play live
Ja gut dass es in may dass in may in den trailer kommt war ja schon sag mal so anfang des jahres man hat er eigentlich ehe richtung april getippt
Das war aber auch klar battlefield 6 will launch on last gen console ja garantiert also da bin ich mir auch sicher dass die
Die aktuelle konsolen generation hat noch nicht genug genug install base dass sich das lohnt also ich denke mal es wird ein bisschen sein wie battlefield
4 war das glaube ich was auch auf den alten und den neuen rausgekommen ist allerdings wird das nicht so schlimm sein wie bei
Battlefield 4 battlefield 4 hatte ja teilweise sogar verkleinerte maps auf der alten xbox und der ps3
In addition to pc in next-gen hardware as for how plausible und im prinzip wird sie auch auf pc am besten spiel
PCmr in quote-unquote leaking stuff about battlefield 6 for over a year at this point most of what he said could be
Reasonably traced to existing info and dice's track record with the franchise the ea play live leak also seems pretty dubious
But at the same time it looks like a logical schedule, so overall. I'd say temper your expectations as always
We'll report on what's out there about battlefield 6, but it shouldn't be taken as anything other than speculation until dice says otherwise. Nein
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen dass level cap sogar schon weiß wie das nächste aussieht und einfach ein bisschen gerüchte küche
Brodeln lässt da sie creator dien hall revealed his next game
Moment habe ich das richtig verstanden das ist der dais der dais daisy creator
As otherwise daisy creator sollte der nicht daisy erst mal fertig machen bevor er neues game rausbringt
Der achter hat sich einfach gedacht drauf geschissen wir machen einfach nichts unfertige game
dien hall revealed his next game igris
It's a survival game that blends the loot in line survival game vom day set creator wer hätte damit nur rechnen können
Und wahrscheinlich genauso unfertig wie der rest if mechanics of escape from tarkov with the hunt showdowns permadeath system you and up to seven other players drop
Da hat da hat die welt drauf gewartet a hostile world the objective is to call da hat die welt drauf gewartet
Complete objectives and extract before time runs out not making it out before the timer hit zero me
Sag mal bin ich der einzige der findet dass das null in die welt reinpasst der tipp mit seinem space suit und den bogen
Das sieht total unpassend aus
Timer hit zero means you lose everything you collected and dropped with unlike most games in this genre
Mission times vary from hours to days and even weeks once you land you have to collect resources and craft tools
Build shelters another op op op das jemals fertig wird eher nicht
To aid your survival completing tasks like building a house and cooking will reward you with points towards progress
It's unclear if the game is solely pve or if those seven other players can also be hostile the steam listing for the game
Specifically calls it a pve experience, but it sounds like even without pvp survival will still be a brutal affair
The world you're surviving on has dangerous animals violent storms and harsh conditions the planet is handcrafted
early access survival game da hat die da hat echt die welt drauf gewartet
Areas or enemy placements, but all of the conditions sound like they'll be dynamic on one run you may have clear skies
But on another you'll face massive storms
Weißte einer der geilsten scams war ja immer noch so in diesem day set hype war ja immer noch wie hieß das
War ja immer noch wie hieß das das war sie dreimal umbenanntet umbenanntet umbenannt haben
Nee nicht h1z1 warts warts genau warts meine ich warts das was jetzt survivor stories heißt genau warts gibt's das überhaupt noch
steam warts das heißt jetzt survivor stories vielleicht
station stories gibt's gibt's da gibt's das noch oh ja hat ja hat ja huge huge reviews
massive reviews
oh mein recent recent recent reviews
most recent bad game
game
ja das ist auch nicht fertig geworden das ist das game wo man sich auf auto stellen konnte und mit der taschenlampe zombies hauen
extraction will take you off world to an orbiting space station the resources you've collected and missions you've completed
will help you upgrade your gear and resources for your next drop a full gameplay trailer is launching on the eighth huge
animations the screenshot and brief glimpse of gameplay available right now looks promising
at least nee ich finde nicht dass es promising looked das looked wie ein weiteres wahrscheinlich
niemals fertig werden des early access survival spiel wo wir schon 30 milliarden billionen von
haben arms of visuals dean studio rocket works is planning to launch the game this year and it'll be
free to play warzone zombie pub crawl is getting slightly more interesting it just moved to the
verdansk tv station and introduced a new armored zombie that's somewhat harder to kill players
have also noticed missile launches happening during matches thanks to a leaked unfinished ad
for the game we know verdansk is getting a cold war themed overhaul that rewinds it in time
that news combined with the most recent updates for the game failing to deliver much needed
improvements has soured the conversation around warzone on social media an egregious invisible
bug reared its ugly head again thanks to the ah stimmt es gab doch ein bug es gab doch ein bug wo man
leute nicht mehr wo man keine headshots mehr verteilen kann ne wo wo der kopf wo die kopf hitbox
despawned wurde sozusagen hab ich gelesen es gab irgendwie einen bug wenn man den passenden skin
ausgerüstet hat hatte dieser hatte der spieler keinen kopf mehr und du konntest den nicht
headshotten das ist modern warfare attack helicopters three months ago players discovered these vehicles
could be used to easily render themselves invisible and invulnerable to damage almost
immediately after the patch went live reports of invisible players flooded social media raven
quickly removed the attack helicopter again but there's been basically no communication about
future warzone updates many players are upset that the ongoing zombies event has been so
underwhelming even more players were hoping for a brand new map not a reskin of verdansk
that said we don't know what activision has planned for the battle royale everything we know about
the game's feature is based on leaks and speculation but it seems like the season is building up to
some sort of explosive finale was mich was mich da an an dem was mich da immer wieder schockt ist
die zeigen so offensichtlich dass sie komplett drauf scheißen und ihnen das spiel eigentlich
vollkommen egal ist und irgendwie sucht es die leute trotzdem durch liegt wahrscheinlich daran
weil es nach wie vor so das beste casual battle royale ist was kein du hast nicht so diese hardcore
inventory management geschichten du hast kein building und rumgejampe wie in fortnite das ist
einfach dass das aber so dass das einzige mainstream so arcade battle royale für jeden
chinese police busted what might be the world's largest video game cheating ring with help from
tencent the authorities worked with tencent to track down the overwatch operation throughout a
12 month investigation the cheating ring was dedicated to selling cheats for a wide variety
of overwatch in 2021 mobile titles they included games like overwatch and league of legends
they sold the cheats in hundreds of countries and regions according to authorities
at the time of the bust police seized 46 million dollars in assets including luxury cars and goods
thanks to initial confusion about the police report estimates put the total revenue earned by the
cheating ring at 700 million dollars but the bbc has confirmed that they only made roughly 76
million dollars in total that's still an obscene amount of money 10 people were arrested in the
police raid and the police took at least 17 cheat websites offline cyberpunk 20 minutes
seven's latest update is a major one that fixes over 400 issues it also makes several tweaks
and improvements to both gameplay and performance and on console players are reporting improved
stability and smoother fps last gen consoles still struggle to hit a consistent 30 fps overall
the patch has been well received but it's also introduced new bugs like permanent sand storms
and gameplay issues the developers still have plenty of patches planned for the future including
free dlcs and paid expansions hey das wäre nice das wäre nice
games be editor jeff grob broke the news during a recent live stream jeff was also recently in the
news for saying dice are targeting may for the reveal of battlefield 6 the games be editor is a
notable industry insider so it's worth taking what also ohne scheiß wenn ich 10 jahre oder
wie wann kam allen weg raus das ist auch schon uralter ich hätte nie im leben gedacht dass
es da mal einen zweiten teil jemals zu geben würde zumal der erste teil keinen wirklich guten
abschluss hatte 2012 ja sagen wir mal zehn jahre das zehn jahre oder oder was auch immer das
rauskommt dass das noch mal einen zweiten teil kriegt das hätte ich im leben nicht gedacht
ok quantum break hätte übrigens auch im zweiten teil verdient allerdings das mag microsoft ja
nicht ja ja moment stripes aber man muss selbst sagen ich fand auch den ich kenne den dlc abschluss
ich fand ihn auch nicht so wahnsinnig gut ja es war auch ziemlich ziemlich verworren alles noch
aber allen weg an sich war wirklich ein super super game das war das ist ein typisches das war so ein
typisches remedy game so nach dem motto vom gameplay her schon cool und auch echt soll
it und und aber das drum herum hat es ausgemacht deswegen war kontrol nicht mein fall ich habe
alle alle remedy games gespielt ja angefangen von max paint 1 max paint 2 allen weg quantum
break so viel haben die ja gar nicht gemacht fand ich alle geil kontrol war nicht so mein fall
ehrlich gesagt das war so irgendwie langweilig weiß nicht aber allen weg wäre auf jeden fall
poggers wenn es da einen zweiten teil von gebe auf der anderen seite war der abschluss jetzt auch
nicht so schlecht dass ich sagen würde das müsste es müsste es haben ja also das war
halt echt verwirrend immer noch und wusste es nicht so was genauer sache war aber
ist am besten der konsideration remedies original allen weg was ein smash hit und
established them as a big-name developer microsoft held the rights to the game for years until remedy
bought them back since then speculation about a sequel has run wild in small part because of remedy
themselves auf jeden fall cool updates an info their most recent title control even had a full allen
wake dlc allen wake 2 will allegedly launch on the epic game store under epics typical deal to
provide upfront funding in exchange for exclusivity it sounds like valve are going all in on the future
of half life two teams at the company are reportedly working on so bedeutet das wirklich half life 3
half life themed vr titles was mehr vorher ok es leak says citadel an rts vr title war players act
is both the commander and the units more recently leaked code in updates for valves other titles
like dota 2 and artifact have hinted at a game in development that utilizes half life alex's core
gameplay mechanics but updated and expanded also sollte ich irgendwann mal eine vr prille holen
dann wird das auf jeden fall gespielt tweaks final story thanks ton for tuning in i hope we covered
all the gaming news that you cared most about if we missed the story that you'd like to know more
about let us know in the comments the launch of co-op looter shooter outriders was rough going
thanks to gameplay bugs so was gucken wir uns als nächstes an ist katz fps da checken wir
sekunde sekunde ah chico ist am start chico ist am start das ist aber echt gut welches bild
hast du denn genommen als basis zum ausschneiden das muss irgendwas sein was ich auf twitter
gepostet habe wahrscheinlich da guckt aber auch kritisch wieder das da ach am waschbecken
chico am waschbecken ja so was gucken wir als nächstes was hab bald vorstellungsgespräche
als fahrinformatiker systemintegration anwängungsentwicklung irgendwelche tips ja guckt
ihr halt an was das für eine firma ist so ein bisschen was über die jeweilige firma oder das
jeweilige unternehmen wie es ja korrekt heißt sonst kommen wieder die leute nach max es heißt
unternehmen firma ist nur der name gibt es ja immer leute die müssen das besonders korrekt
sehen alles bis denn machs gut ich würde mir einfach ein bisschen angucken was die so treiben
ja weil das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt und sei es nur wenn die was erzählen da kannst du
dann quasi so so einsteigen weil du ja quasi das so furchtbar interessant findest und zufälliger
weise das halt ist auch was die machen ja also ich würde auf jeden fall vorher mal angucken was die
was die treiben aber ansonsten ja weiß nicht also schwer schwer zu sagen es ist sicherlich nicht
verkehrt aber das heißt ja wahrscheinlich deine bewerbung schon geschrieb wenn ich als
anwendungsentwickler bewirbst du hast vielleicht schon ein paar sachen also ein bisschen vorkennt
ist kannst du das ja noch mal erwähnen es kommt immer ein bisschen auf die jeweilige firma an wie
gesagt ich hatte halt mega glück bei meinem einstellungsgespräch dass zu gut gelaufen ist
und ich habe mich halt null vorbereitet aber das würde ich halt nicht empfehlen das war
halt eher lucky es fack ja ach ja und in der regel ok ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ob das die
regel ist weil das war bei mir so ich weiß nicht ob das die regel ist aber ich denke mal wenn du
die überzeugt geht es schnell also bei mir war so ich war ich war da hab einen vorstellungsgespräch
gehabt anderen tag acht Uhr morgens rufen die mich an und sagen ja hier wir würden sie gerne
einstellen das ging super schnell hätte ich nicht gedacht dass dauern wir da zwei wochen
sagen du guckst immer wo bloß und max fps das kommt sicherlich gut so was gucken wir als nächstes
making lego car climb slopes exzellent exzellent kogas
ja also wenn du sowas noch nie gemacht hast ist das bestes was du machen kannst ist dir
vorfeld angucken was die firma so macht oder du musst da gar nicht unbedingt jetzt im detail
wissen weil kannst du es ja gar nicht wenn du nicht da bist aber einfach was die auf ihrer
homepage schreiben was sie was sie also die ganzen haben die ganzen unternehmen haben ja auf ihrer
homepage immer stehen warum sie so geil sind so und das ist nicht verkehrt sich das mal durch
zu lesen und im vorfeld zu gucken ok was schreiben die dann über sich was so geil ist das zu wissen
ist nicht verkehrt oh jetzt kommen die fetten die fetten wheels jawoll
oh
ok lass mal ok ok ich überlege was passieren könnte ob es klappt oder nicht ich meine es
könnte klappen dass es mit genug power eben hochgefahren es könnte aber auch sein dass
es ein umkippen wird es wahrscheinlich noch
das das könnte umkippen guck mal das ist relativ schwer hier hinten und das ist ziemlich steil
das könnte umkippen er könnte dann vorbeugen indem er das ding weiter in die mitte macht
oder weiter vorne hin oder so excellent excellent ok es kippt ja ok doch sag mal so es kippt
es kippt im endeffekt um ok das kann man auch machen ich hätte gedacht er versucht
es eher das gewicht noch ein bisschen mehr in die mitte zu machen aber da wird die wand
hochgekockert nope nope nein keine chance
ok das beschiss das ist wirklich beschiss jetzt klebt es einfach dran ok das aber dann
recht recht starkes klebeband six hat klebeband ok da bin ich mal gespannt ob das klebeband
stark genug ist je nachdem was es ist vielleicht aber nachdem er das zum rollen immer abgehen
muss zwischendurch glaube nicht dass es funktioniert ok das ist das noch mal extra extra cheat
gut das kann man natürlich machen aber das ist jetzt schon hardcore cheat ok gut jetzt
wissen wir wieder bescheid unglaublich wichtiges video das wir da jetzt geguckt haben ok das
müssen wir uns jetzt angucken excellent konnte man nicht schon seit seit irgendwie die letzten
frag mich nicht 25 jahre playstation modden ok aber vielleicht nicht softmode man musste
irgendeinen mod chip einbauen glaube ins cd laufwerk damals ne aber softmode bedeutet
ja man muss ohne dass man die öffnen und einbaut kann man die flaschen da haben sie aber lang
das hat aber lange gehalten die wie die wie konterste konterste quasi nach nach irgendwie
kann und im jahr flaschen softmode ist sie die switch die switch kannst du noch über
den browser irgendwie modder crisp hdmi signal tap directly from the video chip but these
modifications are enthusiast level upgrades that require opening up the system and installing
complex pieces of electronics most of them aren't for the beginner and would require
someone who's experienced with soldering these modifications also don't run cheap even a
simple standard mod chip for a playstation one as popular as they were back in the day
requires some experience with soldering and you still need to purchase a mod chip but what
if you just wanted to play playstation one discs without a mod chip maybe you own a big
cd folder of backup games and you wanted to play them on a playstation one in the past
this would not be possible unless you had a mod chip installed but thanks to a save game
alternativ kann man die games auch mittlerweile relativ gut auf dem emulator playen
wenn das ding hat einen parallel port
war das konnte leute leute ich muss ich muss ich muss ich muss gestehen ich hatte zu dem
zeitpunkt als es angesagt war keine playstation eins konnte die cds abspielen musik jahne
the parallel port then you're out of luck tony hacks works on all model playstation ones and it works by utilizing a buffer overflow exploit in tony hawks pro skater 23 for both pal and ntsc regions to load a backup loader unlock a few that is
ja fast ein bisschen wie der twilight hack of the week so rather than me just talking about it let's take a closer look and see how this exploit actually works now i've got a backup copy here of final fantasy tactics for the ps1 and i'm just gonna put it into my playstation one or my ps1 here just to show you that the the system is not modified in any way
wenn der passion wird sein video wegen hacking gleich auf youtube gebannt
this is a completely unmodified ps1 that we're looking at here and after probably just a couple of seconds here it should tell me that this disc is not readable please insert a playstation format disc now on this particular memory card i have saved games for both tony hawk 2 and privatkopier ist so lange egal wie du kein kopierschutz umgehst original disc for the ps1 so now we're resetting our ps1 and it should boot directly into tony hawk 3
and i'm just going to skip over the intros and the menus and all that stuff and just get into it here the exploitable save games are on the memory card attached to the ps1 here and we've got save games for both tony hawk 2 and tony that is a bit like the twilight hack of the week
kennt ihr, kennt noch einer den twilight hack für the week da hast du auch twilight princess gebraucht und manipulierten spielstand und dann musstest du rückwärts laufen und mit dem npc sprechen der den name vom pferd ausgesprochen hat und der name von deinem pferd war manipuliert in dem spielstand und dadurch ist es dann quasi an andere an eine andere speicherstelle gesprungen weil dein pferd einen zu langen name hatte
ganz abgedrehtes zeug
basically load the game here and then we want to select create a skater and watch what happens here when i pick create skater
now as you can see here after a second or so we're in tony hacks and basically what we do now is get our backup copy tony hacks
that we tried to run previously and we will swap it into our ps1
die frage ist überlebt das ein reboot oder nicht
actually letting us put a disk in here
ja die pokemon speedruns gar nicht
and after a short while it will boot into our backup copy of the game
and it should only take about 10 or 15 seconds or so but it does depend on the cd that you've you've made a backup of of course some work better than others
but as you can see it's boot into our introduction here and we should be into final fantasy tactics running on a completely unmodified original sony ps1
that has not been tampered with has not been opened with in any shape or form and this is how tony hacks works it's a very simple very elegant but a really awesome way to play playstation 1 backup games on your original ps1
backup selbstverständlich selbstverständlich ist das ein legit backup von einem spiel was er besitzt
sag ich doch sag ich doch genau genau ich sag's doch am anfang
ja
all jetzt kommt big brain tactics
wabbel
Ein Wobblers.
So heute am Abend.
To effectively boot from a backup CDR.
What's even easier is that opening and closing the tray won't disable or reset the unlocked state that the drive is in.
Which makes it possible, as we saw with Tony Hacks, to simply swap in a CDR backup once the drive has been unlocked and closed the tray.
These unlock commands were documented by Martin Korth, who you may know from the no-cache emulator line.
And interestingly enough are supported on every single Playstation CDR on BIOS.
From almost the very earliest model all the way to the late model PS1s.
Incidentally, I also tested...
By the way, ich hoffe ja, dass man auch mal die Stadia Chromecast modden kann.
Weil ich mein Stadia selbst...wird ja vielleicht demnächst abgeschaltet.
Da kann man vielleicht mit den Dingern noch was anfangen.
Das geht anscheinend nur mit Tony Hawk 2 und 3. Und einem manipulierten Spiel schon auf einer Memory Card.
Okay, es geht mit mehr Spielen.
Hab ich nicht.
Ich habe eine PS3.
Mann.
Na ja.
Man könnte es doch einfach auf dem Emulator spielen.
Was ist denn an Enderalph Special Edition anders?
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Aber 1999 hätte Sony richtig geraget.
Ja, Skyrim Mod.
Also 1999 hätte Sony richtig geraget.
Die hätten alles verklagt und weggebannt, was irgendwie nur zu verklagen und wegzubannen ist.
Jetzt juckt die das nicht mehr großartig.
Aber damals wäre da wirklich die Kacke am Dampfen gewesen bei Sony.
Kann ich mir richtig vorstellen.
Sobald es dann auch easy as fuck ist, dann hätten die Leute 1999 auf dem Schulhof irgendwelche Safe-Game-Dinger getauscht oder so.
CPU-Köpfen.
Das wollte ich mir angucken.
Weil ich habe ja einmal, ich habe es ja selbst einmal gemacht, eine CPU zu köpfen und es war echt eines der schwitzigsten Dinger, die ich je gemacht habe.
Der Auer ist wieder am Start, ja.
Wir können uns auch noch 20 Minuten Battlefield 3 angucken.
Ne, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, wie der Auer die CPU köpft.
Hier ein bisschen lauter.
Cuts am Start.
Das ist doch auch wieder so ein 800 Euro Mainport, oder?
Welche hast du geköpft?
Ein 8700K habe ich geköpft.
Und Leute, ich habe geschwitzt bei dem, also ich habe hier einen 8700K.
Mal gucken, ob es da sogar vielleicht ein paar Bilder davon gibt.
Ich habe sogar Bilder, glaube ich, mal gepostet von mir, wo ich geköpft habe.
Vielleicht finde ich noch was.
Ja, habe ich nie hochgeladen.
Ja, ich fürchte mal, Bilder habe ich da nie hochgeladen von.
Vielleicht habe ich irgendwie köpft.
Ich hoffe, ich kriege jetzt keine Monka-Toss-Bilder.
Okay, ne, habe ich nicht, aber das sieht dann ungefähr so aus.
Ja, genau, ungefähr so sieht das aus.
Das machst du auf, dann hast du hier neben diesen komischen Silikonring.
Und ich habe das damals versucht, mit einer Kreditkarte abzumachen.
Leute, könnt ihr vergessen, das ist so hartnäckig, das Zeug.
Ich habe da ewig dran rumgekratzt und rumgekratzt.
Aber es ist ein komisches Gefühl, ja, so ein Teil hatte ich auch.
So was hier in der Richtung.
Ich hatte irgendwie Delid-Mate oder sowas hieß das Ding.
Ne, Delid, Doktor, nicht Delid, Doktor Delid.
CPU, sowas hatte ich, genau.
Da steckst du die CPU rein und dann drehst du die Schraube rein.
Und das dreht dann die CPU.
Und ich sage euch, es ist ein ganz komisches Gefühl, wenn ihr eine 600 Euro,
oder ich weiß gar nicht wie viel, ne, 400 Euro, 50 Euro CPU habt, die nicht erhältlich ist.
Das war damals ja auch so, die waren nicht erhältlich.
Ich hatte übelst Glück, ich hatte bestimmt eine der ersten CPUs in Deutschland davon.
Ich hatte drei vorbestellt bei fünf verschiedenen Shops und in der Hoffnung, ich bekomme einen.
Und es ist ein ganz komisches Gefühl, wenn ihr da eine CPU dreht und die CPU knackst auf einmal.
Und ihr denkt, Scheiße, wenn die CPU jetzt kaputt geht, dann könnt ihr die nächsten vier Monate mit dem Rechner nichts machen.
Aber es hat alles funktioniert, ja.
Und dann sieht es am Ende so aus, wenn ihr das abgemacht habt.
So hier, da habt ihr diesen Silikonkleber drum.
So der Vorteil davon ist, der Vorteil davon ist, dass ihr direkt, also ihr macht dann hier Flüssigmetall drauf
und könnt es wieder oben draufkleben und gut ist.
Deswegen muss man auch das Silikon abmachen, weil das Silikon sonst zu hoch ist
und der Heatspreader keinen Kontakt hat zur drunterliegenden Oberseite von der CPU.
Genau.
Und da spürt man ein bisschen Flüssigmetall drauf, da Flüssigmetall drauf und dann drückt man es drauf und gut ist.
Deswegen habe ich bis heute Angst, meinen Rechner zu öffnen und den CPU-Lüfter abzumachen,
weil ich habe das nicht wieder richtig verschraubt, das ist einfach nur drauf.
Da geht dann wahrscheinlich Instant-Rip, wenn ich den CPU-Kühler abmache.
Egal.
11700K geköpft, das habe ich in einem bisherigen oder zurückliegenden Video schon mal ein bisschen genauer erklärt.
Ah, guck mal hier.
Island Vera Bithalter. Okay, wir müssen erst mal vorspulen.
Das sind wieder so 800€ Mainboards.
Wann sollen die 600€ gekostet haben? Kann auch sein, dass es nicht 600€ gekostet hat.
Als die ganz neu waren und nicht lieferbar waren, haben die auf jeden Fall ein bisschen mehr gekostet als das, was UVP war.
Denn wir müssen erst mal checken, wie sind die Autos mit 5100MHz relativ ansprechend und wir wissen ja,
dass der 11900K bzw. die 11. Generation so ein Update am Raumcontroller wird.
Ich habe ein bisschen Vorspurle.
Wie viel er ist, da wollen wir erstmal sicher gehen.
O-Exit-Multimeter stellt es.
1,6 Volt an.
Ich will das Köpfen sehen.
Das hört sich immer gewalttätig an.
Aber wo wird die CPU geköpft? Ich will sehen, wo die CPU geköpft wird.
Hier.
Excellent.
Der Bauer ist ja der Hardcore, der macht das ja auch mit einem Teppichmesser.
Das ist noch vertretbar, die Temperatur.
Okay, dann kommen wir jetzt mal zum interessanten und wahrscheinlich auch schwierigen Part.
Der ist ja der Hardcore drauf, mit einem Teppichmesser wird bei dem geköpft.
Den 11900K als Vergleich habe ich hier nochmal einen 10900K organisiert.
Und den 9900K, beide schon komplett geköpft.
Warum muss man die überhaupt köpfen?
Ich dachte, mittlerweile hat Intel auch wieder Heatspreader und CPU verlötet.
Da muss man noch gar nichts mehr wirklich sinniger, oder?
Oder verstehe ich nicht.
Also einen 8700K musste man halt köpfen, wenn man die ein bisschen übertakten will.
Weil Intel hat sich gedacht, wir schmieren einfach Wärmeleitpaste zwischen Heatspreader und CPU.
Also der 9900K, 10900K, die unterscheiden sich nur minimal.
Hier einfach nur ein bisschen längerer die.
Aber grundsätzlich sehr, sehr simpel gehalten.
Komplett flache Platine, nichts drauf.
Und zum Vergleich eben beim 11900K, das was wir schon vorab mal angesprochen hatten.
Da haben wir eben das große Problem mit ein paar SMD-Teilen, die um den Heatspreader rumliegen.
Und hier auf der anderen Seite auch nochmal angehalten.
Das wird den Köpfprozess um einiges schwieriger machen.
Ich stelle mir das jetzt erstmal so vor.
Wir wissen ja, dass hier unten drunter unter dem Heatspreader auch nochmal eine Reihe ist.
Das bedeutet, wir werden erstmal versuchen den Heatspreader so minimal in diese Richtung zu schieben.
Weil wir haben hier so geschätzt 3mm Platz und hier drüben so 1,5 bis 2mm.
Das heißt, es wird schon möglich sein, den Heatspreader ein Stück in die Richtung zu schieben.
Ohne dass wir die Teile hier hoffentlich beschädigen.
Weil in die andere Richtung können wir nicht schieben.
Da sind nämlich die anderen Teile drunter.
Ja dann.
Das wird jetzt erstmal der Versuchsansatz sein.
Aber guck mal, ist das das offizielle der Bauer Köpftool?
Das wollte ich mir damals auch kaufen, aber gab es gerade nicht.
Und da habe ich mir dieses andere Teil gekauft.
Kann man die Dinge eigentlich auch für neuere CPUs verwenden?
Im Prinzip schon, oder?
Die Technik ist ja immer noch die gleiche.
Also das Gute ist auf jeden Fall, dass wir oben gerade noch so reinschauen können.
Wir sehen es zwar nicht mega gut, aber es ist nicht verdeckt.
Leute, dieses Geräusch, wenn CPUs knacksen, das ist nicht gut.
Ich sage euch, also er hat das ja schon 100.000 mal gemacht, den juckt das nicht mehr.
Aber das ist echt Paynes Champ, weil man denkt, gleich ist er kaputt.
Wow, was ist hier los?
Subscriptions am Start, huge subscriptions.
4 Abos verschenkt, danke schön. Und zwar, wer kriegt denn was?
Lauren2698, IC4NT5TOP, was heißt denn das? ICANTSTSTOP, ergibt keinen Sinn, aber du hast einen Sub.
Eastside und MartinLu, exquisite subscriptions, danke schön, massive.
Oh, knack, knack, knack, oh nee.
Also zumindest mal reingefühlt, da braucht man auf jeden Fall mehr Kraft als beim Vorgänger.
Ich vermute mal, das liegt daran, weil der Die eben viel größer ist, dementsprechend auch die Schärfläche deutlich größer ist.
Scheint so, als brauchen wir hier ein bisschen mehr Kraft als gedacht.
Jetzt kommt der gute, die gute Vera Zyklop Knarre mit dem Porgas Vera Bits Halter.
Die sollten mich übrigens auch mal sponsern, so viel Werbung, wie ich für die mache.
Alter.
Die Splitter hat sich jetzt auf jeden Fall bewegt.
Jetzt öffnen wir mal das Ganze und schauen uns das an.
Also wir sehen zumindest mal, es hat sich bewegt, es hat sich ein Stückchen bewegt, ja.
Hier an den Komponenten sind, also da können wir.
Oh nee, nee, nee, weiter geht nicht.
Dann ist RIP.
Nicht weitergehen, wir werden den Heat Spray jetzt mal zurückdrücken, wieder nach oben.
Einfach ein bisschen hin und her wackeln, vielleicht geht es ja auf.
Und jetzt versuchen wir ihn quasi wieder in die Original Position zu bringen.
Und dann schiebe ich das Ganze wahrscheinlich mal so zehnmal.
Warum macht man sowas an seinem Rechner zum Spaß haben und lernen, aber okay, aber normalen PCs.
Naja, zum Beispiel bei dem 8700K, wenn du den übertakten wolltest, das ging schlicht und ergreifend nicht wirklich.
Weil Intel hat sich gedacht, sie schmieren Wärmeleitpaste zwischen Heat Sprayter und CPU.
Das war schlecht, die Dinger waren schon quasi mit normalem Takt Allcore Turbo, waren die komplett am Limit.
Und ich habe da schon noch einiges rausgeholt, dadurch, dass ich das geköpft habe und Flüssigmetall dazwischen geschmiert habe.
Ich glaube normaler Takt beim 8700K waren maximal 4,7 Gigahertz, oder?
Oder sogar 4,3? Nee, 4,7 mit Allcore Turbo, ne?
Also standardmäßig 4,3, aber das kann man ja schon erhöhen, indem man einfach sagt, Maximal Turbo für alle Kurs.
Dann hast du 4,7, glaube ich, gehabt.
Und ich konnte es übertakten bis auf 5,1, allerdings mit ordentlich mehr Spannung.
Das hat sich nicht so wirklich gelohnt, aber auf jeden Fall eine coole Sache.
Und jetzt ist halt der Vorteil, ich habe es jetzt wieder auf normalem Takt, aber Allcore Turbo an.
Und es bleibt wirklich nice kühl.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine Sache, die ich nicht jedem empfehlen würde, ja.
Schauen wir mal, ob es sich löst.
Und falls es sich nicht lösen wird, hat sich zumindest mal der Kleber gelöst und wir müssten die CPU dann noch ein bisschen warm machen.
Ah, erstmal schön mit der Heißluftpistole draufsprayen.
Wir hitzen, dass es flüssig wird und dann den Heatspeller abnehmen, das wäre dann die Alternative.
Okay, das Ganze ist mir ein bisschen zu heike.
Also ich habe die CPU jetzt minimum zehnmal hin und her geschoben.
Geht nicht.
Und ist immer noch relativ fest, das ist einfach, weil das Indium, was das Ganze verbindet, ultra zäh ist und eben sehr, sehr weich.
Das bedeutet, man müsste das eigentlich ein bisschen weiter schieben können, um das abzulösen.
Deswegen lieber ab in den Ofen damit.
Der Backofen hat gefühlt in seinem Leben, in der Hardware gesehen, als fitzen.
Ich frage mich immer, es gab ja auch diesen Trick mit Xbox in Backofen und sowas machen.
Kennt ihr vielleicht noch den einen oder anderen.
Ich frage mich immer, ob man nicht irgendwelche Rückstände dadurch im Backofen behält
und man quasi auf der nächsten Pizza dann irgendwelche Überreste von Xbox oder der Intel CPU drauf hat.
170 Grad Celsius. Sollte passen bei ungefähr 150, schmilzt das Zeug, 155.
Xbox, äh, iPhone in der Mikrowelle aufladen.
Ja, das war doch die Geschichte, wo Leute ihr iPhone reinweise in die Mikrowelle geschrottet haben.
Und ihre Mikrowelle vielleicht mitgeschrottet.
Intel schmeckt besser als AMD, sprichst du aus Erfahrung, ja.
Ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen, dass die Bestandteile von dem Headsquader Kleber ganz besonders auf Salami Pizza
nochmal so den richtig exquisite Geschmack geben, ja.
Ah, yes. Exzellent.
Okay, das hat eigentlich schon mal ganz gut funktioniert, soweit ich das zumindest mal beurteilen kann.
Ich habe hier oben so eine kleine Minimacke reingemacht auszusehen, während ich den Heatspad abgelöst habe.
Ich hoffe, die CPU hat das Ganze überlebt. Wir werden das auf jeden Fall...
Ja, da oben ist ja hoffentlich nichts.
Jetzt heißt es erstmal CPU säubern. Bevor wir die CPU säubern, erstmal so ein genereller kurzer Einblick.
Wir können ja mal die CPU eben vergleichen, optisch mit dem 10900.
Erstmal kurz die CPU abrubbeln.
Und da sieht man einfach, dass das Zeug abgeht.
Es ist ziemlich krass, wie viel größer der die geworden ist. Also es ist schon echt einiges, viel mehr Platz.
Wenn das futsch wäre, würde er das nicht uploaden. Vielleicht, aber auf der anderen Seite.
Er hat auch schon Videos hochgeladen, wo er Zeugs aufs Mainboard geschmissen hat und es zerrissen ist und sowas. Also kann schon sein.
Hier gar nicht tatsächlich. Da wären wir dann schon Richtung High-Core-Count-CPU. Also hier Skylake X und so weiter.
Auch krass, wenn wir den Heatspaddler anschauen, ist das der erste Heatspaddler von den Desktop-CPUs, den ich gesehen habe, der komplett ihnen vergoldet ist.
Die anderen waren ja immer nur teilvergoldet. Also da, wo man dann letztendlich auch...
Ja, deswegen ist die Frage halt, bringt das überhaupt was, die zu köpfen?
Bei meinem 8700K verstehe ich es ja mit... Also man sieht ja hier, der Unterschied ist, hier ist Metall dazwischen, zwischen CPU und Heatspaddler.
Und bei dem 8700K, den ich hatte, war das kein Metall, sondern quasi nur Wärmeleitpaste dazwischen, die nicht richtig geleitet hat.
Auch so eine billige 5-Cent-Wärmeleitpaste. Bringt es das da überhaupt?
Hatte zum verlöten, aber hier ist einfach der ganze Heatspaddler ihnen mit Gold vergoldet. Also das macht man ja, damit das Indium ein bisschen besser hält.
Nico, zuerst Dankeschön für den Sub! Hyper Subscription!
Okay, nächste Tipp, säubern wir jetzt erstmal die CPU und den Heatspaddler. Das bedeutet hier, den ganzen Kleber entfernen.
Auch beim Heatspaddler den ganzen Kleber entfernen. Dann das Indium-Load hier abkratzen und auch den Heatspaddler.
Und dann werden wir zum Schluss Flüssigmetall auftragen und dann kommt das Ganze wieder zusammen.
Und dann funktioniert das Ganze hoffentlich. Natürlich die SMDs noch ein bisschen abdecken, dass da nichts passiert.
Also die äußeren brauchen wir nicht abdecken, aber die unteren hier zur Sicherheit.
Ja, okay. Ich werd geschabt.
Mit was schabt der denn da? Was ist denn das, was er da hat? Das geht erstaunlich gut ab.
Ich hab da ewig dran rumgekratzt, bis ich das Silikon abhatte.
Sieht aus wie irgendwas aus dem 3D Drucker.
Ja, erstmal schön. Teppich, Messer. Und jetzt den Finger, Monka Toss.
Heatspaddler ist schon gesäubert. Bei der CPU ist es ein bisschen schwieriger oder risikobehafteter,
weil man natürlich nicht abrutschen sollte in die Platine. Und wir wollen ja auch keine von diesen Teilen da unten irgendwie ablösen.
Oh, das sieht echt so aus, als geht's kaputt, Alter.
Das ist Painschamp, ich beim Zugucken.
Mit dem Teppichmesser, mit der Teppichmesserklinge auf der CPU.
Wenn du da abrutscht, ist das halt RIP, ne? Also eventuell für den Finger und die CPU.
Eine Frage für mich ist natürlich, wie hoch ist der Chip? Also das ist der 10900K.
Ah hier, beste. Die habe ich auch drauf, auf der CPU. Thermal Grizzly Conductor Node hier.
Der Heatspaddler in der Mitte ist ca. 2,6mm dick. Und darauf können wir auch ein bisschen schließen.
Schauen wir mal, bevor wir jetzt den Chip vermessen, ob sich da was getan hat bei der Chipdicke.
Wenn wir jetzt einfach nur den Heatspaddler in der Mitte machen.
Ja, ich weiß. Ich weiß, dem gehört das irgendwie mit oder er kriegt da zumindest Kohle vorn.
Das ist quasi das Originale der Bauerwärmelheit-Paste. Oder flüssig-metalligierung.
Ok, das ist tatsächlich interessant. 2,36mm, das ist so ziemlich genau das gleiche, was wir beim 9900K hatten.
Ah, jetzt. Alles klar.
Würde das zumindest darauf schließen lassen, dass der Die wieder höher ist, wie beim 9900K.
Macht er nicht auch Puddings. Puddings, das ist der große Bauer, der Puddings macht.
Dann müssen wir jetzt mal kurz die Die-Höhe dazu. Einfach die CPU.
Der Kopf-CPU ist...
Der ist dann nicht mehr mega praktisch, weil ich hier unten flache Oberflächen habe, um die Bügelmeßschraube anzulegen.
Schauen wir mal. Ok, also Die-Höhe 0,6mm. Und damit eigentlich ziemlich identisch.
0,64, hier müssen wir ja schon mal ganz korrekt sein.
Zum 10900K, das ist interessant. Irgendwie dachte ich...
Ok, ich finde es jetzt nicht so interessant, das liegt aber einfach daran, weil ich die anderen CPUs nicht habe, mich wie Null damit beschäftigt habe.
Aber anscheinend, was ich interessant finde, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist, dass es ähnlich dick ist, wie die anderen CPUs, die er vorher...
Der wäre höher.
Es bedeutet natürlich, dass entweder das gesamte Package, also die ganze CPU, dünner wurde, was ich mir nicht vorstellen kann.
Sonst würden die Güle ja nicht mehr so passen. Oder die Platine wurde dicker.
Checken wir mal kurz die Platine. Also 10900K, ca. 1,13mm dicke Platine.
Ja, da haben wir den Höhenunterschied. Die Platine ist dicker geworden vom 11900K. Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant.
1,23mm, das ist auf jeden Fall für die Direct Die ziemlich geil.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine ziemlich gute Entwicklung. Also wenn wir bedenken für die Direct Die, dass jetzt eben nicht nur die Platine...
Dann machen wir einfach genau richtig, einfach gar keinen Heat Spriter mehr drauf, sondern direkt auf die CPU.
Das bedeutet, die ganze Platine hier hat mehr Stabilität, der Die ist deutlich größer, wir haben mehr Auflagefläche auf dem Kühler.
Dadurch weniger Fläche von der Platine, die sich durchbiegen kann.
Und dadurch, dass die Platine schon dicker geworden ist, ist es sogar möglich, dass wir vielleicht gar keinen Direct Die Frame brauchen für diese Generation.
Vielleicht reicht da tatsächlich so eine Plastikunterlagscheibe, die wir hier gelasert haben.
Exquisite.
Dann schützen wir jetzt mal die Komponenten und dann kommt Flüssigkeit auf.
Ist das Nagellack?
Okay, es ist wahrscheinlich so eine Art Nagellack, nur als CPU-Tuning verkauft.
Ja, das habe ich auch bei mir drauf.
Genau, dieses Wattestäbchen ist dabei.
Ihr bekommt so ein Wattestäbchen dabei und man kann das auch nur mit dem originalen Wattestäbchen halbwegs gut verteilen.
Dann setzen wir den Deckel mal wieder vorsichtig drauf.
Klebt, Champ.
Ich werde ihn jetzt für den ersten Test mal nicht verkleben, sondern nur so montieren.
So habe ich das bei mir übrigens auch drauf.
Ich habe es auch nicht neu verklebt.
Ich habe es einfach wieder so reingesetzt, Lüfter drauf und fertig war.
Ich bin gespannt, ob das Ding noch lebt.
Aber mal kurz anmachen und schauen, ob die CPU 00 macht oder vielleicht ein bisschen mehr.
Perfekt.
Erst mal kurz einen Cinebench R20-Check, einfach nur um zu schauen, ob die Temperaturen passen oder ob wir einen groben Fehler gemacht haben.
Und dann machen wir die wirkliche Analyse mit Prime95.
Sieht eigentlich ganz angenehm aus, muss ich sagen.
Sieht ziemlich angenehm aus, temperaturtechnisch.
Okay, also die Performance passt schon mal.
Dementsprechend müssten auch die Temperaturen eigentlich passen.
Aber das Setup lief jetzt eben auch nicht schon ewig kalten wie gestern.
Dementsprechend werde ich das erst mal in 15 Minuten alles mal schön aufhalten mit Prime95 und dann testen wir das richtig.
Okay, ich habe jetzt alles in Ruhe noch mal ausgewertet, weil ich mich gerade beim...
Guck da die Katze raus hinter dem Monitor.
... ersten Anblick schon mal gewundert habe, warum die Temperaturen im Cinebench R20 so viel niedriger waren als vorher.
Gerade wenn man bedenken, dass es eben eine verlötete CPU ist.
Und da habe ich eigentlich persönlich...
Ja, das ist die Katze, die raufkommt.
... drei oder vier Grad Celsius erwartet wie vorher.
Und nicht jetzt plötzlich zehn Grad, was es auf den ersten Blick war.
Ich habe dann alles doppelt gecheckt, alle Settings waren identisch.
Kernspannung, die Raumtemperatur war 0,1 Grad niedriger jetzt als gestern.
Also 0,1 Grad, das hat nicht diesen riesen Einfluss.
Deswegen kann man das quasi ignorieren.
Und wir schauen uns jetzt auch mal die Ergebnisse an.
Ihr seht oben die rote Linie.
Durchschnittstemperatur nach 15 Minuten Aufwärmphase, Prime95 12K.
Haben wir hier eine Durchschnittstemperatur über alle Kerne.
Okay, das ist schon ein ordentlicher Unterschied.
Aber warum? Warum ist es so ein großer Unterschied?
Ich meine, vorher, bei den alten mit den Wärmeleitpasten dazwischen, verstehe ich das.
Aber jetzt waren die Dinger quasi...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das Verlöte nennen kann, aber der war ja schon Metall dazwischen.
Ist das so viel besser, diese Cryonaut-Legierung,
Conductor-Naut-Legierung, als das, was Intel da drauf macht?
Die Schichtdicke macht es. Aha.
Okay.
Das liegt am Nagellack, wahrscheinlich.
Ich muss echt sagen, ich kann es mir nicht erklären.
Für mich klingt es nach zu viel.
Ich habe alles doppelt überprüft.
Alle Sachen, Wassertemperatur, alle Einstellungen in den BIOS, Leistungsaufnahme.
Die Leistungsaufnahme können wir uns auch anschauen.
Die habe ich da auch noch mal drauf geplottet.
Da seht ihr vor dem Köpfen ca. 297 Watt und nach dem Köpfen ca. 8 Watt weniger.
Also es kann schon sein, wenn man so eine CPU 10 Grad kühler hält,
dass die dann 8 Watt weniger Leistungsaufnahme hat.
Das kommt auf jeden Fall hin.
Also Leistungsaufnahme passt, alle Parameter haben gestimmt.
Ich weiß nicht, warum der Temperaturunterschied so krass ist.
Das habe ich auf jeden Fall nicht gedacht.
Und bevor ich jetzt hier irgendwelche Empfehlungen ausspreche,
würde ich wahrscheinlich darauf warten, bis jemand anderes auch mal seine CPU köpft
und das Ganze vielleicht bestätigt oder dementiert.
Weil für mich klingt es nach zu viel.
Das sage ich euch ganz ehrlich.
Aber ansonsten, wenn es sich beschädigt, wäre es natürlich...
300 Watt für die CPU ist, das ist nicht ein bisschen viel.
Nö, warum?
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich All-Core Turbo volle Pulle AVX Instruction in your face.
Also mehr geht ja auch gar nicht.
Das ist quasi das Maximale, was du machen kannst dann.
Ich würde sagen, Köpfen von diesen CPUs enormes Risiko.
Mit diesen ganzen SMB-Teilen außen rum,
man kann nicht einfach Scherbewegungen machen und abschieben, das wird nichts.
Da könnt ihr garantiert irgendwelche Teile abscheren.
Also davor würde ich euch auf jeden Fall warnen, das solltet ihr nicht tun.
Das heißt, man muss so eine Kombination machen,
das ein bisschen wegschieben, dass der Kleber sich löst,
dann in den Backofen abnehmen, das ist wahrscheinlich die safest Methode.
Da würde ich sagen, es ist ein enormes Risiko, dass man bei diesen CPUs was zerstört.
Deswegen würde ich es nicht unbedingt empfehlen, dass man das macht.
Er würde wahrscheinlich empfehlen, wir gehen alle zu Caseking
und kaufen uns pretestete CPUs.
Würde ich aber auch machen, gib Money.
Rausgesetzt natürlich, man wartet jetzt erstmal ab,
bis jemand die Temperatur unterschiede bzw. Ergebnisse bestätigt.
Ansonsten, mit dem neuen BIOS war das Board dann auch deutlich besser.
Übrigens, die Spannungslandertemperatur während dem Test,
die lag immer bei straight 80°C.
Wenn wir bedenken, dass wir hier eine CPU-Leistungsaufnahme von 300 Watt haben,
und hier Zero Airflow bei diesem Setup,
sind 80°C bei einer Spannung absolut top wert.
Sobald es in dem Gehäuse sitzt und dann nur der minimalste Airflow drüber geht,
dann haben wir da wahrscheinlich eher 65-70°C.
Ich wollte mal vor Jahren, das ist eigentlich fertig, das Video.
Ich wollte vor Jahren mal was mit Caseking machen.
Und Caseking war damals noch auf dem Stand, sie wollen kein Geld bezahlen,
sondern ob sie mich nicht bezahlen können mit einer Wasserkühlung oder so,
haben die damals geschrieben.
Dann habe ich das Video hochgeladen, das Video hat 150.000 Aufrufe gehabt.
Und danach meinte Caseking, ja lief ja doch ziemlich gut.
Aber danach hatte ich nichts mehr mit dem Kurs zu tun danach.
Bezahlung in Naturalien, genau.
Bezahlung in Cheeseburger.
Das hätte ich mir vielleicht sogar überlegt, aber keine McDonald's-Cheeseburger,
sondern richtig gut ordentliche Cheeseburger.
Best Battlefield Maps of All Time.
Okay, ich sag euch mal, was die besten Battlefield Maps of All Time sind.
Das ist ganz easy. So easy ist das gar nicht.
Port Walters ist auf jeden Fall ganz vorne mit dabei.
Okay, reden wir mal von Rush. Wir reden nur von Rush.
Wir reden nur von Rush, nur Rush.
Das heißt nur Rush Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5 fallen schon mal raus,
weil Rush gesackt hat.
Port Walters war die beste Battlefield Maps of All Time.
Port Walters, Port Walters.
Diese House Map aus Bad Company 1, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie die heißt.
Terran Highway, übelst underrated Map, mega geil in Rush.
Dema Van Peak definitiv.
Dema Van Peak ist eines der geilsten Rush Maps überhaupt.
Walparaiso.
Wir gucken einfach mal, wir skippen mal.
Caspian Border mag ich persönlich gar nicht.
Wir skippen einfach mal kurz drüber.
Okay.
Okay, Battlefield 2, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Stimmt, Simd Kakan war in Battlefield 2 ziemlich staubig, ja.
Da ist ja in Battlefield 3 nichts von übrig geblieben.
Was da für Arnele Musik im Hintergrund.
Ja, weil in Battlefield 3 ist er nullstaubig mehr.
Die haben das doch in Battlefield 4 Remake, ne.
Ja, die haben das doch in Battlefield 4 Remake, ne.
Ich wette mit euch, Wake Island ist dabei und ich muss sagen,
meinetwegen 1942, Battlefield meinetwegen, aber gerade in Rush in Battlefield 3
und allgemein, das hat sich nicht gut gespielt in den Teilen danach.
Es war klar, dass es kommt, war klar.
Schwuss.
Da, gut, das gab es 1943, gab es das, ja, 1943 Remake, Battlefield 3 Remake, ja.
Ja, ich kann mich noch mal dran erinnern.
All-out War Experience, da hat er sich auch ein bisschen viel von DICE inspirieren lassen.
Ah, jetzt Caspian Border, ne, never, wäre das auf meiner besten Map-Liste, never.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nur wegen der Antenne, vielleicht, ne, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich mag Caspian Border nicht, ich kann machen, was ich will, aber es ist nicht meine Map.
Also, wenn ich in Battlefield 3 Map raussuchen müsste, dann Demavent Peak.
Ah, Arika Harbor, da würde ich unterschreiben, ja, das würde ich unterschreiben.
Rush gibt es bessere, aber das lasse ich mir gefallen, ja.
Ne, der Film sagt mir nichts.
Ja, das unterschreibe ich auf jeden Fall, das unterschreibe ich so.
Ja.
Gut, das ist zu alt, kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Guck mal, wie groß die Maps damals auch waren, ne.
Ja, also rein Infanterie-Action würde ich das auch mitnehmen.
In Rush ist die halt übelst unfair, aber ja, ja, würde ich auch, würde ich auch so sehen, ja.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Demavent Peak, Demavent Peak, wenn ich an Battlefield 3 denke, ohne Scheiß Demavent Peak.
Hardline Remake kann ich mir nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Okay, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Habe ich eventuell mal gespielt, keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
War das die Beta-Map?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, dann habe ich in der Beta mal gespielt, aber keine Ahnung.
Aber die habe ich so gut wie nie gespielt.
War das eine DLC-Map?
Ja, DLC.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Aber kein Demavent Peak drinne.
Ohne Scheiß, das ist...
Ich hätte auf, also ich hätte Caspian Border rausgelassen zum Beispiel, hätte Demavent Peak reingenommen.
Beste, beste Map.
Nein, Quatsch.
Und ich kriege Hunger, es ist erst 12 und ich habe übelst Hunger, was ist hier los?
Pornvaldas war auch nicht dabei, ja gut, ich meine, kann ja nicht alles, was ich sage, da genau so sehen.
Wo wir gerade bei Battlefield sind, wollen wir noch eine Runde Battlefield, wollen wir noch eine Runde Battlefield 3 Top Plays gucken?
Komm, wenn wir gerade schon bei Battlefield sind, gucken wir uns das jetzt noch an.
Excellent.
VU ist dead.
Leider, oh nee, das ist wieder, schon wieder der Typ, Alter.
Das sind immer die gleichen Clips.
Der Typ sitzt irgendwo am Arsch der Welt auf Caspian Border und snipet.
Immer das Gleiche.
Der macht die ganze Runde nichts, außer das.
Ich meine, das ist sicherlich mal ganz hilfreich so ein Feed, aber das macht er halt einmal an den 5 Runden oder so.
Ja, wir haben vorhin in VU reingeguckt, es war Meisterserver, hat 6 Spieler gehabt.
Mit Bots, lul, weh.
Ok, das ist ein nicer Feed.
Sag mal, bewegen die sich nicht? Wollen die geschneibert werden?
Ist das Console Graphics, Leute? Console Graphics?
Oder einfach nur jemand mit schlechter PC Auflösung?
Ich erkenne nicht, was es für eine Plattform ist, was ist es für eine Plattform?
Ich würde sagen Xbox oder so, aber es können auch PC sein.
Es können auch PC sein, einfach mit schlechter Auflösung.
Weil der aimt mir ein bisschen zu gut mit dem Tank für Controller.
PC? Woran sieht man das?
Ach guck mal, das ist Venice, das ist Venice, nur einfach in schlechter Auflösung.
Das ist Venice, nur in schlechter Auflösung, lul, weh, Alter.
Ok, wenn der Venice Clips nimmt, dann schicke ich ihm einmal einen Metro Clip ein, wo ich irgendwie 25 Leute weggesprayt habe.
Try Hard Setting.
Ja, aber das Game läuft auch so gut.
Oh, schreckt.
Kennste Alpha 4 Games, klar.
Ok, der macht es nicht übel.
Oh, die Alter, die kriegen ja mal mega auf den Sack, Alter.
Ok, down.
Wir haben es auf der Konsole, den Farbenblind-Modus, ich glaube schon.
Das ist auch VU, guck mal auch VU.
Das ist der Pink Server, das ist da, wo ich vermutet habe, dass die ein oder anderen Leute cheaten.
Aber kann man nichts beweisen, ja.
Switch-Emos werden immer besser.
Ja, aber das habe ich nicht bei Alter 4 Games geschrieben, sondern bei Sump, glaube ich.
Da werden sie weggesprayt.
Also es besteht durchaus die Chance, dass ich auch in dem Game gewesen bin, wenn er mal das Leaderboard zeigt.
Leaderboard zeigen.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Leaderboard zeigen.
Save und Q-Chat, Leute, Q-Chat irgendwo am Start.
Nein, da war ich anscheinend gerade nicht drauf, ok.
Kein Q-Chat.
Oder zu weit unten, ja.
Aber ich stehe ja nie unten im Scoreboard, da kann ich nicht drauf gewesen sein.
Nee, da war ich nicht drauf.
Und da hätte man hier oben schon mal irgendwie was gesehen.
Zumindest, dass ich gekillt werde.
Alter, die werden aber schon ordentlich weggesprayt hier, die Jungs.
Da ist er wieder.
Ja, beim Star-Battler bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob da alles legit ist.
Oh, nice, das da drüben mit der Pistole ist nicht übel.
Der hat teilweise echt nice Clips.
Den haben wir auch glaube ich schon zweimal gehostet, also der ist wirklich gut in dem Game.
Nice.
Oh, da werden sie weggesprayt, mit der UMP.
Die UMP.
Sprayt alles weg.
Oh.
Alter, die kriegen auf den Sack, ey.
Ich dachte, er wollte drüberspringen ohne Messer oder so.
Boah, aber nicer Streak, ultra-nicer, ultra-nicer Streak.
Der spielt nur mit, oder?
Backrage, excellent Backrage.
Aber immerhin, immerhin wird richtig nice revived.
Das habe ich schon öfters bei ihm im Stream gesehen.
Er spammt immer alles voll mit Smoke und dann gibt es in your face, genau.
Alter, mit der Pistole, wie resound.
Und vor allem, wie sie nicht checken, dass er da ist, lull.
Oh, in your face, Alter.
Geil.
Lull.
Poggers Clip.
Visiert er auch mal an.
Ach was, wozu?
Ja.
Schau mal, wie viele Spieler versuchten ihn runterzulegen.
Es war nur ein bisschen Panik für sie, den letzten Mann.
Um ehrlich zu sein, hätte er wirklich ein bisschen besser gemacht.
Er ist glücklich da, Dusty, dann drückt ihn durch.
Ein absolut fantastisches, objektives Spiel.
Jawoll, bam.
Drei Stück.
Boah, die lassen sich auch wieder richtig
übertrieben wegsprayen.
Bazaarbeste hier. Hui.
Darfst du nicht zu lange peeken,
dann bist du dead.
Also das ist halt so ein typisches
Battlefield-Training. Es explodiert
einfach die ganze Zeit was um dich.
Das ist übrigens das, was ich in Venice
an Leash tatsächlich ganz gut finde,
dass ein bisschen dieses
Gescheike ausgeschaltet wurde, weil
du kriegst ja da fast schon
Motionsignis bei.
Zumindest wenn du das eine Weile spielst.
Und jetzt lege Hände.
Gib die lege Hände.
Jawoll. Lege Hände.
Nice.
Nice, lege Hände.
Spray sie weg.
Jawoll.
Boah, intense, intense
Fight hier.
Also das M-Com haben sie nur ihm zu verdanken.
Metro!
Please.
Kipp mal ein bisschen was anderes als Metro.
Oh, C-Combatant-Server hier.
Oh, jawoll.
Jawoll, Bam.
So muss das sein.
Ich wäre erst noch mal über die
Ammo-Kiste gelaufen.
So muss das sein.
Und so hat das hier fundiert.
Montage von daar ab pregnancy.
〜
Montage von da ab pregnancy.
nicht richtig klar ist das koreanisch kann durchaus sein aber der server ist russisch
mehr metro clips pleats
und ein nicht nochmal
please
die tippen macht den ganzen tag nichts anderes ich sage nicht dass es easy ist das immer zu
hitten aber es naja gut jeder wie er will aber trotzdem
das klub noch 4.000 point chain wieder eine tolle konsistenz in dieser verrückten range
president sleeper please hatte auch glück dass die alle rumstehen sich nicht bewegen
was hat der typ im chat geschrieben lol so many snipers
wie lange geht das noch
es sieht mehr aus wie eine stadt no shit commentator
jetzt bettel viel drei eigentlich auf stadia
gesprayt
bei magenta gaming a verstehe die map ist schon ganz schön kaputt ist das hardcore
nee da wäre jetzt schon tot der gegner lul weh alter das gerade was hat er für
der sense
der nächste auf der Liste, den du am unteren sehst
wirklich tolle Sachen
gunmasters freaks sind nice zu sehen, nice zum gucken
und dass er den noch genau scoped hat, alter, ah, Mist, Mist, knapp
ah, Metro, wer hätte das gedacht
by the way, ich weiß Battlefield 3 Tipps in 2021
man kann hier oben aufs Geländer
von der Treppe laufen ist viel besserer Winkel als über die Rolltreppe
oh, da werden sie weggesprayt, so ist das gut, nice
oh, da werden sie weggesprayt
ey, Karl reloadet mir einfach zu langsam
ich bin wieder backraged
guckt euch mal an wie der da gekillt hat
alter, der wohl eine neue Grafikkarte will, wie es aussieht
ja, ich würde ja, das ist ein Video, ja, aber ich würde ja tatsächlich ein bisschen Battlefield 3 wieder spielen, aber Venice is dead
aber die werden schon heftig weggesprayt ey
oh, wie es ruckelt, was sind das, 12 FPS
das können von der Grafik tatsächlich auch Konsole sein, aber ne, hier mit dem Overlay nicht
was musst du eigentlich für ein Rechner haben, wenn du auf Noshark Canals maximal 90 FPS bekommst mit der Auflösung
oder ne, da hat die FPS gecapped glaube ich
naja, wobei, bin ich mir da zu sicher
top, der hat einfach einen kack Rechner
using that Magnum quite a bit, danke für diese super big brain commentary im Hintergrund
vielleicht auf dem alten Gaming Laptop ja
oh, der war cool, das war nice
I get fucked in the ass over hier
und check, na gut, das ist halt der typische Sniper Spieler gewesen
weggesprayt
Shotgun
okay, der hätte vielleicht das Video einen Ticken heller machen können, dass man auch was sieht
zack
oh, hört ihr es im Hintergrund, der hat ein Mikrofon laufen, man hört Tastaturgeklicke
was hat die für ne Range, ich würde ja sagen Slug Ammo, aber ich bin mir da nicht so sicher ehrlich gesagt
Spaß 12, ja, das ist normal kein Slug denke ich auch
ja, Users Frac klar, Metro, nochmal Metro, wer hätte das nur für möglich gehalten
kennt ihr noch hier links diese Kiste wo man sich reinlegen konnte
ah, da werden sie aber schon nice weggesprayt
das ist halt das coole auch irgendwo gewesen auf Battlefield 3
du konntest theoretisch die ganze Runde kacke spielen und hattest dann aber trotzdem mal so einen nice 15er Streak zwischendurch
also auch Leute die sonst nicht so geouten haben, du hattest immer mal so die Situation wo du eben gerade zur richtigen Zeit an der richtigen Stelle warst und massiv weggesprayen konntest
zum Beispiel hier so Posis, gibt so ein paar Posis, die sind halt einfach OP
Bäm Bäm Bäm, Sebaro ist am Start
die lassen sich aber auch wieder weghauen, meine Güte
jetzt ist er down, wollte ich gerade sagen also wenn er das überlebt dann verstehe ich es nicht
das ist ja jetzt los
aber erst mal das passende Emote dazu
ich geh jetzt auf, ich muss jetzt nämlich was essen und dann muss ich ein Video aufnehmen
ja wir haben katz FPS Emote jetzt
ich installiere mir Bad Company 2 und ich mach den deutschen Jackfrax, ich mach einfach ein Video Bad Company 2 10 Jahre später und schneide einfach ein paar Clips zusammen
und laber ein bisschen was zu
aber Jackfrax hat sich sogar richtig easy gemacht, der hat einfach nur in game mit aufgenommen beim labern
also Leute wir sehen uns, machts gut vielleicht bin ich nachher noch mal am Start, mal gucken
das brauchst du, weiche Plush Schlafmaske
ok Aliexpress was auch immer, was auch immer
das ist Pepe Maske light
also Leute
wir sehen uns, ein Cent
wow was ist da drüben los
ist das Monka Toss
nee nee nee man sieht nix man sieht nix man sieht bloß Photoshoppen Bobbes
Bonus für neue Benutzer ok alles klar
alles klar Leute wir sehen uns, bis dann machts gut, CU